TODAY'S.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING AN EXCITING
TRANSITION BEING OFFERED A
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
IMPROVE OUR SERVICES.
IN YOUTH RESTORATION.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS ACROSS THE
AUTOMATION PROJECTS THAT ENABLE
MAJOR PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE WE DO THOSE HOWEVER WE
WILL BE TAKING ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN OUT OF ORDER.
THAT WILL BE THE SECOND ITEM WE
WILL BE -- HEARING BEFORE WE GO
ON TO THE OTHER SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION PROGRAMS.
AND IS ALWAYS TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING MOVING
FORWARD DURING OUR LIMITED TIME
TOGETHER.
WE DO ASK ALL PANEL IS TO BE
SUCCINCT IN THE PRESENTATIONS
AND TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
UNDER THREE MINUTES.
AND DURING PUBLIC COMMENT WE DO
ASK THAT PUBLIC COMMENT BE
LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE.
WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE I WANT TO WELCOME.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
CHUCK SUPPLE DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
CHRIS CAN'T FROM THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES TO
DISCUSS THE CREATION OF A NEW.
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION WITHIN.
THE HHS AGENCY.
HI.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S
A PLEASURE AND HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. TO MOVE DJJ.
INTO A NEW DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
AT CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
AND WE VIEW THIS AS A CRITICAL
STEP ON THE JOURNEY OF
STRENGTHENING DJJ IS ABILITY TO
FULFILL OUR VISION AND MISSION.
UTILIZING SOME KEY STRATEGIES
AND I JUST WANTED TO HIT ON A
LITTLE BIT OF A HISTORY.
WITH BACK IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES THE THE HEIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA THE THIRTIES
POPULATION THERE WERE SOME
THIRTEEN THOUSAND YOUTH.
WHO ARE IN EIGHT DJJ FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND FIVE
FIRE CAMPS AND TODAY THERE ARE
THREE FACILITIES?
AND ONE FIRE CAMP AND TODAY I
THINK SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWO
YOUTH WHO ARE IN THOSE
FACILITIES AND FIRE CAMP.
SO THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
DRAMATIC -- DEVOLUTION SO TO
SPEAK OF THE POPULATION OF YOUTH
THAT ARE IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS CERTAINLY.
WITHIN THE STATE'S DEEP AND IF
YOU WILL -- PORTION OF THE
SYSTEM AND THAT HAS BEEN A
RESULT OF A NUMBER OF REFORMS
LEGISLATIVE -- OVER THE YEARS
POLICY INITIATIVES -- AS WELL AS
A DECREASE IN JUVENILE CRIME
JUVENILE ARRESTS.
HOWEVER WITH THAT LEAVES DJJ
WITH -- IS THE STATE'S MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHAVIOR EARLY --
AND MENTALLY CHALLENGED YOUTH.
WE HAVE COME OUT OF A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT -- SUCCESSFULLY THREE
YEARS AGO AND HAVE MANY OF THE
TOOLS AND STRATEGIES THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS POPULATION.
BUT MORE WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE
AND THE THREE KEY STEPS BEFORE
US ONE IS.
TO A SUSTAIN AND ADVANCE THE
GAINS OF THE FERAL LAWSUIT
PARTICULARLY THE CONTINUED.
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT WE CALL
THE INTEGRATED BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT MODEL WHICH IS A WHOLE
ARRAY OF EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS
ASSESSMENT INSTRUMENT -- IT TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF THE YOUTH THAT WE ARE
LEFT TO SERVE.
AND TO CONTINUE TO CULTIVATE A A
CULTURE THAT IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT THAT SUPPORTS THE THE
MISSION AND I SEE THAT AS A
CULTURE.
OF SUCCESS AND FINALLY.
TO BUILD UP WHAT I CALL THE
STRENGTH BASED SPACE OBVIOUSLY A
CRITICAL PORTION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
AND ADDRESSING THE POPULATION
THAT WE ARE ENTRUSTED TO SERVICE
TO HELP THEM TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THEIR RISK TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS.
THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF THE
CONDITIONS THE PAST EXPERIENCES
THAT CONTRIBUTED TO THEIR
DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR.
BUT A BIG PART OF IT AS WELL AS
HELPING THEM TO BUILD UPON THEIR
STRENGTHS TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO
IMAGINE THE POSSIBILITY OF A
DIFFERENT IDENTITY FOR
THEMSELVES AS WELL AS TO PURSUE --
YOU KNOW PASSIONS -- IN A
DIFFERENT FUTURE ORIENTATION TO
GET A NEW LIFE SO TO SPEAK TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN SAFELY TO THE
COMMUNITY BECOME RESPONSIBLE
SUCCESSFUL ADULTS.
AND AT THIS PARTICULAR PART OF
IT THIS PARTICULAR TIME INDEED
JJ'S JOURNEY THE TRANSITION TO
CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
HELP US TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER ON
THAT MISSION THROUGH
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
LANDS TO BE ABLE TO CONNECT WITH.
RESOURCES THAT ARE CRITICAL BOTH
IN TERMS OF OUR OWN DELIVERY OF
SERVICE AS WELL AS SERVICES
THEY'RE GETTING PORT. FOR THE
TRANSITION OF THE YOUTH BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
FAULT LEAVE IT AT THAT HOPEFULLY
THAT WAS THREE MINUTES AND
CERTAINLY CAN ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS WE GO
ALONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JUST
LIKE.
TO REITERATE THAT YOU KNOW WE
REALLY SEE THIS IS OPPORTUNITY
GROW ON THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN
MADE AT DJJ YOU KNOW THE HEALTH
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES WE
FOCUSED ON REHABILITATION
INTEGRATION AND PERSON
CENTEREDNESS AND THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN DEVELOP
A DJJ.
AND WE THINK WE'LL FOSTER AND
GROW WITH HIM SERVICE AGENCY
BOTH IN THE LARGER MISSION AND
HELPING TO CONNECT -- DJJ TO
LOCAL ENTITIES UNDER OUR PURVIEW
SUCH AS HOLES SERVICES AND MEDI
CAL.
SO DOES REINFORCE THAT POINT NOW
KEEP IT SHORT.
ORTEGA'S GIVING A VERY SHORT.
THANK YOU -- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ERIN EDWARDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ADDITIONAL TO ADD -- TO
WITH MISTER -- SUPPLE MISTER
KENT NOTED BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
LEAKAGE MORROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IN
CONCERN THIS PROPOSAL WE
IDENTIFIED A FEW QUESTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER.
THE FIRST OF WHICH WOULD BE
WHETHER OR NOT TO DJ.
NEEDS TO BE REORGANIZED TO
IMPROVE REHABILITATION.
AS MENTIONED THE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE DJ ENTERED INTO THE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT CONTENDS THAT
HAS TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS TO
IMPROVE REHABILITATION EFFORTS.
THEY EXITED THIS LAWSUIT IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN HOWEVER THE MOST
RECENT REHABILITATION AND
CITIZEN DATA WE HAVE TO RE
CONVICTION RATES -- FORTY MORE
TO HAVE LEFT DJ IT'S FOR THE
CODE THAT.
LEFT IN 200-011-2000 TWELVE
SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE THAT
LAWSUIT ENDED AND SEVERAL YEARS
FROM CURRENT STATE.
SO IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW EFFECTIVE
THE CURRENT PROGRAMS IN.
DE TODAY ARE AT REHABILITATING
YOUTH.
IN ADDITION WE WOULD WANT TO
CONSIDER ONE OF THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF ITS REORGANIZATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS MENTIONED
SEVERAL POTENTIAL BENEFITS
HOWEVER IT'S NOT GOING TO CLEAR
HOW THESE BENEFITS WOULD BE
OPERATIONALIZED.
AND THE NEXT QUESTION WOULD BE
ONE OF THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
REORGANIZATION.
WITHOUT KNOWING HOW THE CAN
OPERATIONALIZE THESE BENEFITS
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THAT WOULD
BE IMPROVEMENTS TO
REHABILITATION.
IN ADDITION IT COULD LEAD TO
INCREASED COSTS STUDENT THE NEED
TO DUPLICATE.
EFFORTS ARE CURRENTLY SHARED
WITH YOU SEE OUR ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND THAT NO COULD ALSO BE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
COMPLICATING THE COORDINATION
BETWEEN.
DJJ NCDC ARW.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE ALTERNATIVE
ORGANIZATIONAL OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
WE LOOKED AT HOW OTHER STATES
HAVE ORGANIZED -- JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
AND WHILE MANY STATES HAVE HAD
THE OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE
ABOUT HALF THE STATES WHO HAD
THIS MODEL HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
IT TO MOVE THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM PRIMARILY INTO EITHER ONE
INDEPENDENT DEPARTMENT THAT'S
NOT UNDER AN AGENCY.
OR INTO -- AGENCY THAT SPECIFIC
TO YOUTH AND FAMILY -- IN
ADDITION ANOTHER OPTION WOULD BE
TO POTENTIALLY REALIGN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
COMPLETELY TO THE COUNTIES.
CURRENTLY ABOUT 13% OF THE YOUTH
WHO ARE IN -- CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA OUR HOUSE
IN THE STATE IN DJ THEIR MAIN
OUR HOUSE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
AND IN ADDITION BOTH THE STATE
FACILITIES AND COUNTY FACILITIES
ARE.
GENERALLY OUT ABOUT A THIRD OF
THE TOTAL CAPACITY.
REALIGNING THE YOUTH TO THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
COULD HAVE THE BENEFIT OF COST
SAVINGS BOTH FOR THE STATE AND
THE COUNTIES AS WELL AS GET PUT
IN THE YOUTH CLOSER TO THOSE.
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS A
FAMILY -- ANOTHER.
QUESTION WE WANT TO RAISE IS
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE USE OF BUDGET TRAVEL
LEGISLATION.
THAT PRIMARY REORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE THE PREVIOUS
REALIZATIONS OF DJ THAT HAPPENED
HAVE A COURT THROUGH --
EXECUTIVE REORGANIZATION PROCESS
AT THAT SALAS BY STATUTE IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHY THIS
REORGANIZATION SHOULD GO THROUGH
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION INSTEAD --
SENSE THE TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS RELEASED
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION.
IN REVIEWING THAT PLEDGE THE
TRAILER BILL WE HAVE.
IDENTIFIED A FEW QUESTIONS THAT
WE SENT OVER TO DEAL OUT -- FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION -- SOME
OF THE CONCERNS OR ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE SEEK ADDITIONAL
COMPLICATION FOR INCLUDE -- THE
PERSONNEL ADJUSTMENTS I WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO MAKE THIS ORGANIZED
REALIZATION HAPPENED
[inaudible]
THE TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE ESTABLISHED FOR
THESE PERSONNEL ON WHETHER TO
APPLY TO ALL PERSONNEL ONLY NEW
PERSONNEL.
WHAT WHY THE THE TRAILER BILL IN
THE REPORT INCLUDES LANGUAGE
REGARDING?
WHY REGULATIONS NEED TO BE WHY
THE?
REGULATORY PROCESS WOULD BE
BYPASS IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS --
FOR THE NEW DEPARTMENT.
AS WELL AS A POTENTIAL NEW
PROGRAM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS THAT WE HAVE
NOT PREVIOUSLY SEEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON HAVE MARK FILL
PART WITH POLICY LINK AND THE
ALLIED SUPPORT SOME OF COLOR --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
COALITION OF LEADERS -- THE TEN
BY TEN COALITION THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOU THINK COMMUNITY
JUSTICE.
AND A WHOLE HOST OF YOUTH
ADVOCATES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I HOPE WE ALL SUPPORT THIS
TRANSITION -- BUT WE ALL BELIEVE
THAT -- IT SHOULD BE DONE IN A
WAY THAT WORKS TOWARDS CLOSURE --
WE BELIEVE THAT -- EXPERTS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ARE
FOCUSED ON THIS IDEA OF CLOSING
YOUTH PRISONS AND THAT THAT IS --
A NATIONALLY.
RECOGNIZED APPROACH -- AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING.
TO HAVE THIS TRANSITION SUPPORT
THAT GOAL -- AND THINKING ABOUT
THE SHRINKAGE OF THE POPULATION
IN A OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS ALL
OF THE RACIAL DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST WITHIN IT.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS.
WE SUPPORT MOVING DJJ INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION OF A TASK
FORCE TO GUIDE THE MOVE IN TO
BEGIN DEVELOPING A BROADER
VISION FOR TRANSFORMING.
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE TEN BY TEN COALITION
HAS SUBMITTED PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND BELIEVE
THAT THEY WILL.
ENSURE THAT THE MOVE A
SUCCESSFUL FINALLY WE BELIEVE
THAT IN ORDER FOR THE MOVE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE DO BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICAL TO STOP THE POPULATION
GROWTH RIGHT NOW.
WE THINK IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE
WHILE WE ARE IN THIS PERIOD OF
TRANSITION GOING FROM ONE SYSTEM
TO ANOTHER TO CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THE POPULATION AT DJJ TO GROW.
AND CONTINUE TO HIRE STAFF IN TO
THE OLD SYSTEM WHEN WE ARE IN
THE TRYING TO TRANSITION THE
CULTURE AND MOVED TO A NEW
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
HELEN ROTH.
THOUSAND SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
WE REPRESENT TEACHERS AND HEALTH
PERSONNEL WITHIN DJJ.
A WE'RE NOT OPPOSING THIS WE WE
THINK THOUGH THAT WORK WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ONE IS THAT
RECENTLY -- WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IS THEY'VE BEEN TAKING
PEOPLE WERE UNDER AGE TWENTY
FIVE AND PUTTING THEM BACK IN
THE DJJ FROM THE DEPARTMENT FROM
THE ADULT PRISONS.
IN THIS COORDINATION HAS BEEN
VERY HELPFUL OTHERWISE -- WHAT
WAS HAPPENING BEFORE DURING --
SCHWARZENEGGER'S TIME FOR
EXAMPLE IS MORE OF A WHEN YOU
REACH YOUR EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY
YOU ARE SENT OFF TO PRISON EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE LIKE WITHIN A
MONTH OF OF GRADUATION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
ON IN THERE NO HIGH SCHOOL SINCE
IN THE BIG CDC ARE BUT THEY ARE
YOU CAN GET A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE ACTUALLY
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
IS THAT -- THERE ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED PRISONERS
WHO ARE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWENTY FIVE IN EIGHTEEN THAT WE
TRANSFER THEM BACK IN TO DJJ
WHICH HAS OTHER SORTS OF MUCH
LARGER RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY HAVE ON CHILDREN THEY HAD
TEACHERS THAT CAN WORK WITH KIDS
WHO HAVE LEARNING DISABILITIES
WHICH THEY DON'T HAVE.
IN IT IN THE LARGER FACILITY IN
ABOUT 30% OF AB IF NOT MORE HAVE
THESE PROBLEMS SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE ALSO A CLOSING THIS
FACILITY YOU HAVE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE KIDS THAT ARE THERE
BECAUSE THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN THE
CARD THEIR CRIME A SEX ABUSE IT
CAUSES THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR PROGRAM IT'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL YOU CAN EXPECT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO REPLICATE THAT PROGRAM.
THERE'S AN ECONOMY OF SCALE IN A
STATE WITH FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
WHERE YOU NEED A FACILITY LIKE
DJJ THAT CAN DO THE SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMS.
IN SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL SO
WITH THAT AND THOSE ARE OUR
COMMENTS AND WE URGE THOSE.
COMMENTS BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MORNING
WASHBURN WITH THE CENTER ON
AND WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL TO MOVE DJJ INTO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
BUT WITH CONCERN THAT -- A NAME
CHANGE ALONE WILL NOT.
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE DAILY LIFE
FOR YOU FROM THE INSTITUTIONS.
AND WE RECENTLY RELEASED A
REPORT LOOKING AT CURRENT
CONDITIONS AT DJJ AND FOUND THAT
THEY REMAIN UNSAFE AND
FUNDAMENTALLY NON REHABILITATIVE.
AND THAT'S DUE TO FACTORS THAT
ARE REALLY ENDEMIC TO CONGREGATE
INSTITUTIONS THE FACT THAT THERE.
REMOTE THEIR PRISON LIKE -- AND
THEIR LARGE SCALE AND SO WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR TASK FORCE TO
GUIDE THIS TRANSITION.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES A SEARCH GREATER
OVERSIGHT OVER DJJ AND
ULTIMATELY MOVE TOWARDS CLOSURE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUPER RAIL AND
I'M WITH THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE TEN BY TEN
WORKING GROUP AND WORKED ON THE
LANGUAGE THAT WERE SUBMITTING --
DID TO FOR INCLUSION IN PROPOSED
INCLUSION IN THE TRAILER BILL WE
SUPPORT THE MOVE OF H. OF DJ TO
HHS BUT WE ALSO AS OTHERS HAVE
SAID.
I THINK THAT IT'SONLY A PART OF
THE PICTURE WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. FOR A TASK FORCE
THAT WILL LOOK BOTH THAT THE
TRANSITION OF DJJ ITSELF AND THE
TRANSFORMATION OF DJJ INTO
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THAN WE
NOW HAVE IT IT SEEMS LIKE THE
PERFECT TIME TO DO THAT.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT WILL WORK
VERY WELL IN HHS BUT WE ALSO
THINK THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR A
MUCH BIGGER POLICY PRESENCE AT
THE STATE LEVEL THAN WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ALL WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS A COMMITTEE WHICH I SERVE
ON THE JUVENILE JUSTICE STANDING
COMMITTEE.
AT THE PSC SEE WHICH MEETS THREE
OR FOUR TIMES A YEAR AND HAS NO
STAFF NO RESOURCES EXCEPT THEY
PAY FOR MY SANDWICH WHEN I GO
THERE.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE WE WE
MUST BE ONE OF THE ONLY STATES
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A STATE LEVEL
POLICY AGENCY -- AND SINCE DJJ
REALLY ONLY SERVES A SMALL
PROPORTION OF THE YOUTH IN
JUVENILE JUSTICE WE THINK THAT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNE TIME TO SET.
PLANS INTO MOTION FOR SERVING
THE BULK OF CHILDREN IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS TIFFANY RIGHT
WITH THAT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL AND
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO
DISCUSS THE TRANSITION AND KIND
OF HOW IT TAKES PLACE -- THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSED THAT
STAKEHOLDER -- TASK FORCE WE
WOULD ALSO AGREE WITH AND JUST
ASK FEDERAL EMPLOYEE A CURRENT
EMPLOYEE BE ON THAT TASK FORCE
SO THAT THEY CAN ALSO ASSIST IN
THE TRANSITION -- AND JUST ASK
THAT THERE JUST BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS --
WITH REGARD TO THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
DAPHNE DESIGN NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR TASK
FORCE AND WOULD URGE THE
THOUGHTFUL COMPOSITION OF THAT
TASK FORCE ALSO INCLUDE.
DIRECTLY IMPACTED YOUTH FAMILIES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE WORKING WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
TRAINED AND TRAUMA.
WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS THE
START AND WE HOPE THAT THAT WILL
BE AND THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE
ON THIS MOMENTUM TO CONTINUE
SERVING OUR YOUTH BETTER TO CUT
BETTER CORDY THE SYSTEMS.
AND TO CREATE BETTER OVERSIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TODAY IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL -- TO MOVE THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE OUT OF THE
ADULT CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM -- I I
DO WANT TO REFLECT UPON KIND OF
THE WHAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MOVING -- DJJ AT THE STATE
LEVEL THAT IS AN APPROACH THAT
WE RECOGNIZE AND UNDERSTAND --
IT'S IT ALIGNS VERY MUCH ¢H
HOW PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE
STRUCTURED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
A SIMILARLY WHICH OPERATES
DISTINCT FROM AT THE ADULT
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM SO IT'S
CERTAINLY AN APPROACH THAT WE
APPRECIATE UNDERSTAND AND
BELIEVE THERE'S THERE TO BE
BENEFITS -- TO I DO WANT TO TAKE
JUST A MOMENT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT -- TO REITERATE AND
HIGHLIGHT THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES OF
PROBATION CHIEFS AND AND MANY OF
OUR OUR STATE LOCAL PARTNERS.
HAVE DONE SIGNIFICANT WORK TO
REALLY LEAD AN EVOLUTION OF
GETTING CALIFORNIA TO A PLACE
WHERE WE HAVE THE LOWEST A
JUVENILE ARREST RATES AND
DETENTION RATES -- IN OUR
HISTORY AND IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK -- WE ALWAYS WANT
TO LOOK TO HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO
BUILD UPON THAT AND ENHANCE --
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT I THINK WHEN
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT WHAT HIS
CHANGE MEANS KIND OF IN THE
CURRENT CONSTRUCT -- DOT SHE
PROBATION OFFICERS AND COUNTY
PROBATION APARTMENTS WORK VERY
VERY CLOSELY WITH -- DJJ AND AND
MISTER SUPPLE AND AND HIS TEAM --
ON THE RE ENTRY OF YOU COMING
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES
CURRENTLY COMING BACK TO THE
COUNTIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SO I THINK AS WORKS WERE
THINKING ABOUT -- MOVING FORWARD
ON THIS PROPOSAL IT'S IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT -- TO THE CHIEFS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON THAT
DIALOGUE KNOWING THAT THEY ARE
COMING BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
AFFECTION WITH THIS CHANGE -- IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS PUBLIC
SAFETY -- BUILDS UPON THE
REHABILITATIVE GOALS IN ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO DO -- SO I WOULD
JUST -- IN CLOSING SAY THAT WE
AGAIN SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL A
SEEDBOX CERTAINLY HOPES TO BE A
PART OF THESE CONVERSE
CONVERSATIONS AGAIN ABOUT HOW TO
EFFECTUATE THIS AND ACHIEVE THE
DESIRED GOALS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MENTOR MEMBERS COULD BE BECAUSE
I'VE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS -- I
HEARD IN TESTIMONY EARLIER THAT.
THE SEVEN HUNDRED OR SO
REMAINING -- JUVENILE OFFENDERS
THAT ARE IN OUR SYSTEM.
ARE SOME OF THE MOST MONTHLY AND
BEHAVE EARLY CHALLENGED
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
SYSTEM AND WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW.
FOR GREATER MENTAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND THERAPEUTIC TREATMENT
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS HELPING
THEM REINTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
CAREERS.
WE WE SO FULLY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL AND WE HOPE TO THE
CONVERSATION WILL GO FORWARD --
WITH MORE AN INCLUSIVE TREATMENT --
OF OF MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES AN
INCREASE OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND%
SIXTY YOUTH.
ARE IN THE SYSTEM AS A RESULT OF
THE RECENT POLICY CHANGES IS
THERE ANY MORE EXPLANATION OR
ANY KIND OF BOX INSIDE YOU CAN
GIVE US ON THAT [inaudible]
ANYONE -- JUST TO BE CLEAR WE'RE
NOT ASKED ME INCREASE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THE YOUTH.
WE'RE ESTIMATING AN INCREASE TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTIETH
ROUGHLY.
SO I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
LIKE AN INCREASE OF ABOUT SIXTY
OR SEVENTY IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THAT WE'RE PROJECTING.
BUT THERE'S AN INCREASE YES AND
THAT IS PRIMARILY RELATED.
TO EXCUSE ME THE YOUNG ADULT
OFFENDER PROGRAM.
WHICH IS IS DESIGNED TO DIVERT --
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE WENT INTO THE ADULT
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM -- TO DJJ
WHERE THEY CAN RECEIVE MORE
ROBUST REHABILITATIVE SERVICES --
WE RECOGNIZE THAT DJJ IS --
BETTER SUITED TO DEAL WITH.
FOLKS YOUNGER OFFENDERS THEIR
PSYCHOLOGY IS DIFFERENT THAN
ADULT OFFENDERS THE RESPOND
DIFFERENTLY TO PROGRAMMING AND
SO THE IDEA WAS TO TO PUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN IN DJJ WHERE THEY
WOULD RECEIVE ARE.
MORE APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
AND THAT'S THE PRIMARY REASON
FOR THE INCREASE IN THE
POPULATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
DIRECTOR SUPPLE AS THAT.
IN A SENSE.
SO I I'D REALLY LIKE READING
ANSWER THE LA US QUESTIONS ON
THE THAT THEY BROUGHT UP BECAUSE
I KNOW I'M SITTING HERE AND IT'S
YOU KNOW I'M HERE AND REALLY
GOOD THINGS FROM FROM THE PUBLIC --
YEAH I REALLY RESPECT THE
OPINIONS OF THOSE THAT THAT WORK
WITH THESE POPULATIONS ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS IN IN HEARING THE
THE PSYCH TAX IN THE PROBATION
OFFICERS IN THE THOSE FOLKS BE
IN SUPPORT.
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WITH
I'VE GOT TO ASK.
WHAT'S STOPPING YOU WALL FROM
DOING THIS NOW.
BECAUSE I I I I WAS A CERTAIN
FOR TEN YEARS I'VE SEEN ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT UNITS ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS OVER
MY LIFETIME.
AND THE WHAT I GOT A FALL UNDER
DIFFERENT APARTMENT TO DO WHAT
YOU KNOW NEEDS TO BE DONE.
BUT WHAT IF YOU GET IF YOU GET
START WITH ANSWERING THE LA OWES
QUESTIONS I THINK THAT BE GREAT
FOR FOR ALL OF US.
IN REALLY THAT THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO NOW I MEAN WHAT.
WHAT'S STOPPING YOU NOW.
ON TOP OF THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
LA.
WELL I THINK THAT.
FUNDAMENTALLY [inaudible]
WE ARE.
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE MISSION.
OF AND THIS IS ACTUALLY IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OF HELPING
YOUTH WHO HAVE HURT PEOPLE.
AND IT DIDN'T HURT THEMSELVES.
RETURN SAFELY TO THE COMMUNITY
AND BECOME RESPONSIBLE AND
SUCCESSFUL ADULTS OKAY THAT THE
DEGREE TALKING POINT WHAT.
WHAT'S STOPPING YOU FROM DOING
THAT NOW FROM WHERE YOU'RE AT
VERSUS CHANGING DEPARTMENT WELL
I THINK THAT BY A VERSUS
CREATING YOU KNOW IT THE AND YOU
COULD DO THAT FOR RIGHT NOW
TODAY [inaudible]
SO.
THE IDEA IS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT.
DJJ SHOULD BE THE LAST STOP IN
THAT SYSTEM THE NEXT STOP SHOULD
NOT BE A CELL ON THE ADULT SIDE.
AND THAT.
IT MEANS THAT.
DOMINANTLY THE LENS THROUGH
WHICH WE LOOK THROUGH HIS
REHABILITATION AS WELL AS
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE.
AT HEALTH PLANS IF YOU WILL.
AND IT JUST MAKES MORE SENSE
THAT.
THAT BE BASED IN AN AGENCY WHO
THAT TWO IS THE PREDOMINANT
MISSION AND FOCUS OF THAT AGENCY
SO ORGANIZATIONALLY AND MAKES
SENSE TO BE AN ORGAN WITHIN AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT SHARES AND IS PREDOMINATELY
ABOUT THE EXACT SAME MISSION
IMPERATIVE WHICH WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE.
TO SERVE THESE YOU THE PROPERLY
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
CAPABLE OF RETURNING SAFELY TO
THE COMMUNITY.
SECONDLY SO MANY OF THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE AND FOR THE
POPULATION THAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO SERVE.
OUR HOUSE WITHIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
AND BY BEING WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE FAR
GREATER OPPORTUNITY FOR CLOSE.
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
WITH THOSE SERVICES THAN BEING
WITHIN CDC ARE.
BUT YOU IS THE DIRECTOR DON'T
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHANGE
THAT MISSION.
WITHOUT CHANGING DEPARTMENTS
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
I HAVE YOU KNOW ISN'T IT WITHIN
YOUR POWER TO DO THAT. TO CHASE
MISSION ABSOLUTELY BEEN TERMS
THE ORGANIZATIONAL SETTING THAT
WOULD NOT BE IN MY PURVIEW TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
WITHIN THE ADULT PRISON SYSTEM
WHEN THE MISSION OF THE
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE TO HELP
GET THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
OUT OF THE CRIMINAL GANGS IN THE
NAME ON THE WALL IS GOING TO
CHANGE HOW THE PEOPLE UNDERNEATH
YOU OFFER A THAT THAT COMES FROM
THE TOP THAT COMES FROM YOU SIR.
ABSOLUTELY AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW
A WE HAVE A NUMBER OF STRATEGIES
THAT I BELIEVE WOULD BE.
MORE EASILY IMPLEMENTED.
WITHIN A HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY AND THAT THE MOST
OF OTHER STATES.
THEIR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
NOT WITHIN THE ADULT PRISON
SYSTEM SO IT'S NOT AN OUTLIER IN
TERMS OF THE THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
KERN [inaudible]
ST.
YES INSPIRATION.
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MANAGER SO I'M HOPING
THAT YOU HAVE HAD SOME KIND OF
METHODOLOGY FOR TRACKING
PERFORMANCE.
ON YOUR OUTCOMES.
I'M HOPING THAT IF THIS DOES
COME TO FRUITION YOU CAN SHOW
ADVANCEMENTS THIS WAS A
WORTHWHILE EFFORT -- AND AS MR
MATHESON SAID THAT IT WASN'T
JUST A NAME CHANGE SO THAT WE
CAN.
KIND OF START.
THE SMOKE AND MIRRORS THING.
SO.
I WANT TO SEE IF THIS IS GOING
TO HAPPEN. TO YOU MAKE STRIDES --
THAT YOU KNOW.
ACTUALLY MAKES THIS A WORTHWHILE.
AND I I COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU
MORE ARE OUTCOME HAS TO BE YOU
KNOW FAR MORE YOUNG PEOPLE
RETURNING TO THE COMMUNITY.
WE NO HARM TO BECOMING
RESPONSIBLE AND SUCCESSFUL
ADULTS -- FRIGHTENING GAUGED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT THAT HAS TO
BE THE PRIZE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE.
AND AGAIN.
IF YOU'VE TRACK PAST
PERFORMANCES AND YOU TO TRACK OF
THE OF FUTURE PERFORMANCES.
THEN IN THE FUTURE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARINGS I CAN BE
SUPPORT OF AND IF YOU'RE NOT
MAKING THOSE STRIDES WELL DON'T
GAMBLE.
YEAH THEN YOU WON'T GET THE
MONEY [inaudible]
SO.
SHOW US THE THE PERFORMANCE SO I
ASK.
IT IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT AFTER
THE FERAL CASE THAT THAT YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT.
THAT THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE DONE BY
D. J. J..
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN YOU
FINALLY WERE ABLE TO CLOSE THE
CASE BECAUSE YOU HAD MADE TO THE
U. HAD COMPLIED WITH WHAT WAS
REQUIRED UNDER THE FERAL CASE IS
THAT NOT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO YOU.
THE WHOLE IDEA AND I REALLY I
PERSONALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS LOOKING TO MOVE.
OUR YOUTH OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS -- THAT ISN'T
WHERE THEY BELONG.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT BUT IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WRIST LOOKING AT RESTORING OUR
USE WE'VE GOT TO FIND A BETTER
PLACE FOR THEM.
I I I DID WANT TO COMMENT --
HOWEVER THAT.
THIS MATTER WAS HEARD SOME.
FIVE AND MANY OF THE SUB FIVE
MEMBERS.
FELT STRONGLY ABOUT HAVING A
LONGER TRANSITION HAVING THE
TASK FORCE PUT IN HAVING
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS.
I A CONCERN AND I HEARD IT FROM
PUBLIC COMMENT AND OTHER OTHER
COMMENTS WE'VE RECEIVED.
IS THAT.
MOST EVERYONE AGREES.
THAT THIS IS A GOOD THING.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS A
GOOD THING -- ART USE FROM ONE
DEPARTMENT TO ANOTHER SO YOU
DON'T HAVE THE DUPLICATION NOT
TRYING TO BRING IN DHHS OVER.
TO DJJ TO PROVIDE SERVICES IT'LL
NOW BE HOUSED UNDER -- DHHS
[inaudible]
BUT THE TRANSITION.
HOUSE TO BE A GOOD TRANSITION SO
THAT.
GOING BACK TO THE COMMENTS FROM
MR MATHESON -- MISTER FRAZIER
THERE WERE SURE THAT THERE'S A
CHANGE.
IN THE CULTURE SO THAT IT ISN'T
JUST TO HELP HOUSING THEM IN ONE
DEPARTMENT SOMETHING UP TO
ANOTHER.
AND THEN LATER TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WITH THE CHANGING CULTURE IS
GOING TO BE.
BUT TO BE SURE THAT YOUR
INTENTIONAL ABOUT THE CHANGE IN
THE CULTURE OF HOW THE YOUTH ARE
GOING TO BE TREATED -- THE
SERVICE IS GOING TO BE PROVIDED.
IT IT IT AND ON AND ON I THINK
THAT.
THE TRANSITION HAS THE CAPACITY
AND THE POWER TO SET THE TONE
FOR YOUTH RESTORATION WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND YES THE TITLE OF THE PROGRAM.
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING BUT A
CÃM.
IF YOU ARE.
IT PROGRAM THAT IS CALLED.
LET ME FIND MY NOTES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN TO BE
HOUSED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
AND REHABILITATION.
AND I THINK THAT -- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT -- IS IS PROPERLY
NOTED THAT WE THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT.
WE WOULD WANT.
THE PURPOSE IS TO CHANGE AND
IMPROVE THESE YOUNG LIVES AND I
THINK THAT -- THE CHANGE WOULD
BE GOOD TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM
NEGATIVE AND TOXIC PRACTICES.
THAT OUR CONSTRUCTIVE.
IN THE INTEREST OF HOPEFULNESS
AND PERSONAL CAPACITY OF THESE
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS.
I DO WANT TO HEAR MORE FROM YOU --
SPECIFIC IT AND APPRECIATE THAT
WE DID RECEIVE THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ALSO -- THAT.
THAT WILL FRAME THE FIRST STEPS
FOR THIS TRANSITION.
BUT A FEW QUESTIONS.
IS THE ADMINISTRATION AMENABLE
TO SLIGHTLY LONGER TIME FRAME.
SPECIFICALLY AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
FOR CONSTRUCTION THE BASES OF
THE NEW DEPARTMENT AND HOW IT
WILL FUNCTION.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW LEE
MINISTRATIONS AS CHRIS CAN'T
FROM HOW HUMAN SERVICES I THINK
WE'VE YOU YOU KNOW THIS INITIAL
TRANSITION FROM DJ TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT.
AS SORT OF YOU KNOW A VERY SORT
OF THIS IS. FOR DEEP GOVERNMENT
STUFF FOR MOVING ALL THESE
POSITIONS OVER GETTING GOING --
YOU KNOW CHUCK IS DOING GREAT
WORK ALREADY CHANGING THE
CULTURE DJJ WERE LOOKING TO
SUPPORT THAT AND WE THINK THIS
YEAR'S TRANSITION IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME FOR THAT.
AND YOU ARE AWARE THAT THOUGHT
THERE ARE MANY WHO FEEL THAT IT
SHOULD BE LONGER BUT I AGREE.
CAN CAN WE WORK WITH YOU
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS TASK FORCE.
A CREATING AN ONGOING TASK FORCE.
DURING THIS TRANSITION OF BUT
WHAT IS DESCRIBED IN THE AGENDA
SO THAT THERE IS A GENUINE
COLLABORATION NOT ONLY WITH OUR
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT BUT WITH
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS.
WHO HOLD EXPERTISE AND VISION IN
THIS FIELD YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT?
THE FERAL IN CENTS FOR ALL.
THERE HAS BEEN THE INVOLVEMENT
OF CONSULTANTS AND STAKEHOLDERS
AND MYSELF -- MOVING FOR AWHILE
I'VE BEEN AT IN INDIRECT RECEIPT
OF WELL AS REGULATE CALLED UPON --
THE ASSISTANCE AND SOUGHT THE
OUTPUT OF THE INPUT OF
INDIVIDUALS BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
SYSTEM.
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSULTANTS AND
I KNOW THAT -- DOCTOR GALLEY AS
WELL IS COMMITTED -- ON AN
ONGOING BASIS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE --
STAKEHOLDERS CONSULTANTS
EXPERTISE AT IN IN THE DECISIONS
THAT WE ARE ARE MAKING AND AGAIN.
SORT OF THAT WITHIN THIS FIRST
YEAR.
SOME OF THAT THE TASK FORCE A
RATHER MUNDANE JUST IN TERMS OF
YOUR YOU KNOW THE GOVERNMENT --
PULLING OUT DISCONNECTING AND
RECONNECTING -- AND THAT IN
TERMS OF THE CRITICAL DECISIONS
AND THE LIKE THAT IS AN ONGOING
PROCESS THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
SEEK OUT.
SUPPORT AND AND INPUT FROM FROM
STAKEHOLDERS EXPERTS IN THOSE
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE SYSTEM
AND BEING ABLE TO TO DO THAT
CORRECTLY.
SO I ASSUME THEN THERE WOULD BE
NO PROBLEM IN CODIFYING THAT.
CONTINUING THE TASK FORCE.
I CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THAT
I'D SAVE YOUR THE MINISTRATIONS
OF HER THE CONCERN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
ALL RIGHT IT WILL TERMS OF NEXT
STEPS I I'M GOING TO ASK -- OUR
STAFF TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
FEEDBACK ON RECOMMENDED CHANGES.
TO THE ADMINISTRATION --
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THE
TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO COORDINATE WITH.
A SUB FIVE WITH THE BUDGET SUB.
FIVE IN ADOPTINGLANGUAGE -- IN
THE MAY REVISE -- WE ALL HAVE A
GOOD BUT JUST A FEW MORE WEEKS
LEFT BUT I THINK IT IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WE HAVE
HEARD FROM SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS --
AND I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A TASK FORCE THAT THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING NEW.
BUT I THINK THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE -- AS
WE DO TRANSITION.
I DO WANT TO REMAIN -- INFORMED
ABOUT THE STATUS AND I'M.
SURE THE REST OF THE THE MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE.
TO REMAIN INFORMED -- AS A
DISCUSSIONS MOVE FORWARD.
OF AND I WILL LAST STAFF TO
CONTINUE IN.
GATHERING THE INFORMATION.
SO THAT WE DO PUT THE
APPROPRIATE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. FOR THIS TRANSITION.
BUT AGAIN I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
I'M VERY GLAD ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
I DON'T I'VE HEARD VERY FEW
COMMENTS.
FROM THOSE SAYING THAT IT IS NOT
A GOOD THING.
WE DO NEED TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
THOUGH AND I THINK THAT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
LEADERSHIP.
OF THE D. EIGHT DHHS IT JUST HAS
TO DO WITH MAKING SURE THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO'D BEEN WORKING
WITH A POPULATION.
ARE HEARD IN DURING THIS
TRANSITION.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE THE PANELISTS FROM
ISSUE ELEVEN TO COME FORWARD
.
YES WHEN WE TAKE FROM -- REYES
[inaudible]
HERE FRAZIER.
AT THIS PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
QUORUM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT. TO TO RINKER. TO LIKE
TO BEGIN OKAY HAPPY TO DO SO
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PITCHER BANK
A CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
WHAT WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS IS AN
ITEM THAT'S IMPORTANT TO US I I
JUST WANT TO OPEN WITH?
A THERE IS NO PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS TIME
EITHER FOR STATE OPERATIONS OR
OR FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
TOPIC OF AN APPLICATION HUB --
BUT IT'S AN ITEM THAT REMAINS OF
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST -- TO US
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS I I
WANT TO APPRECIATE THE STAFF AND
A THOROUGH DISCUSSION OF THE
ISSUE.
AND PERHAPS TURN TO PAGE --
FIFTY FOUR IN THE AGENDA TO TALK
ABOUT THE KEY OBJECTIVES OF WHAT
AN APPLICATION HUB IS.
IN A NOT SHOW IN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS PEOPLE COME FORWARD THEY
PRESENT INFORMATION COUNTY STAFF
GENERALLY SPEAKING TO HAVE TO
VERIFY THAT INFORMATION RECORDED
IN SYSTEMS THAT SAT TRACK -- IT
THAT K. THAT INFORMATION
EXCHANGE CAN HAPPEN IN A VARIETY
OF WAYS IT CAN BE ELECTRONIC --
UGH PEOPLE CAN I HAVE TO BRING
IN HARD COPIES OF THEIR PAY
STUBS TO PROVE INCOME -- THEY
COULD PROVIDE UTILITY BILLS FOR
PROOF OF UTILITY COSTS OF THE
THAT THAT -- DEDUCTIONS AND SOME
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS SEES.
ARE WE HAVE THREE DIFFERENT --
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
CONSORTIA SYSTEMS THAT THAT
PROCESS ELIGIBILITY THEY ALL
HAVE DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES IN
TERMS OF DOCUMENT MANAGEMENT AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
AND THEN SOME OF THE
VERIFICATIONS THAT WE DO WITH
DIFFERENT DATA SOURCES LIKE THE
NEW HIRE DATABASE OR EDT WAGE
EARNINGS DATABASES.
OR OR OR RESIDENCY THEY CAN BE
ELECTRONIC OR NOT -- AND SO
REALLY THE GOAL OF THE PROJECT --
IN YOUR AGENDA LACES OUT NICELY
ON THIS PAGE FOR CLIENTS CLARITY
ABOUT WHAT'S REQUIRED AND WHEN --
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW WE DO THE
VERIFICATIONS AND AND THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE RELYING
ON THEY SHOULD BE INFORMED HOW
WE'RE VERIFYING WHAT THEY GIVE
TO US.
REDUCING PAPER IF THERE'S A WAY
TO ELECTRONICALLY PROVIDE
SOMETHING APPLYING DOES HAVE TO
GO FETCH AT A DOCTOR'S NO PROOF
OF IMMUNIZATION WHATEVER IT
HAPPENS TO BE FOR A PARTICULAR
PROGRAM.
IF WE CAN DO THAT ARE LIKE
TRONIC LEE AND LEAVE THE
PAPERWORK BURDEN THAT'S CLEARLY
OF A BENEFIT TO US -- AND BEING
ABLE.
TO UPLOAD DOCUMENTS FROM YOUR
HOME OR A MOBILE PHONE IN YOUR
PAJAMAS WITHOUT HAVING TO BRING
THEM DOWN TO A COUNTY OFFICE IN
PERSON.
HAND THEM TO SOMEBODY GET THEM
STAMP TO AND UPLOAD IT THAT'S
CLEARLY A BENEFIT FOR CLIENTS.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
PROGRAM STAFF HANDLING THAT THE
LAST PAPER THEY HAVE TO TOUCH
THE MORE TIMELY THAT WE CAN
VERIFY THE INFORMATION GIVEN TO
US.
FROM A QUIET AND AND COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE YOU GET ACCURATE
MORE ACCURATE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS MORE ACCURATE
BENEFIT DETERMINATIONS -- AND
MORE EFFICIENCY IN THE PROCESS
TAKING LESS TIME TO DO THINGS SO
BENEFITS ALL AROUND.
ON PAGE.
OF FIFTY THREE SUMMARIZES -- IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF -- THE
THE DEPARTMENT COMMISSIONED --
SOCIAL INTEREST SOLUTIONS IT'S
CONSULTING FIRM THAT WE OBTAINED
AFTER A BID PROCESS. TO DO A
MASSIVE STAKEHOLDER A REACH THE
INCLUDED CLIENTS AND COUNTIES
AND OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS.
AND AND THE THE FINDINGS THERE
ARE ARE SUMMARIZED FOR YOU ON
PAGE -- FIFTY THREE IT'S NO
SECRET THINGS ARE COMPLEX ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS HAVE DIFFERENT
RULES WE USE DIFFERENT IT
SYSTEMS FOR IT -- HOUSEHOLD CAN
BE DEFINED AS AN INDIVIDUAL AS A
FAMILY THAT'S RELATED TO EACH
OTHER IT CAN BE FAMILIES SPIKE
FOR CALIBRATION THAT ARE IN A
HOUSEHOLD THAT PREPARES MEALS
TOGETHER SO YOUR ROOMMATE COULD
BE INCLUDED IN THAT DEFINITION.
OF SO DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS ACROSS PROGRAMS AND
WHAT WE NEED TO VERIFY.
AND SOME PROGRAMS ARE ON ANNUAL
RENEWAL -- SOME ARE ON QUARTERLY
OR SEMI ANNUAL -- ACTUALLY NOT
TOO MANY ON QUARTERLY ANYMORE --
AND AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
YOU KNOW NOT TIMELY ACCESS TO
ELECTRONIC -- SOURCES OF
INFORMATION AND THAT THE PROCESS
IS A BIRD IN SOME IN SOME OF
THOSE THINGS SO THERE'S A LOT TO
THINK ABOUT AS WE THINK AS WE
CONSIDER WHAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
DO AN APPLICATION HUB -- IT'S
NOT JUST STUFF THAT AFFECTS MY
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
THE PROGRAMS WE OPERATE BUT
OTHER DEPARTMENTS IN AGENCY
COULD POTENTIALLY USE THE SO THE
CONCEPT OF AN APPLICATION HUB.
IS EXACTLY THAT IT'S A HARD
THAT'S A A FUNCTION.
KIND OF LIKE THE THE HUMAN
EQUIVALENT OF YOUR OFFICE
MANAGER IN YOUR OFFICE IT'S THE
PERSON THAT EVERYBODY NO MATTER
WHAT THEY'RE DOING GOES TO TO
FIND CERTAIN STUFF LIKE WHERE
THE PANS.
HOW DO I GET THERE WHO DO I TALK
TO TO JOIN THE WATER CLUB WHERE
ALL THE QUESTIONS GET ANSWERED?
THAT'S THE ELECTRONIC EQUIVALENT
THAT WE'RE THINKING OF HERE WITH
A HARD PROCESS -- SO AS I SAID
IN THE BEGINNING WE DON'T HAVE
AN ACTIVE PROPOSAL FOR YOU IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED THOUGH IN PURSUING --
ANYTHING THAT WE DO IN THIS
REGARD BECAUSE ITS CLIENT FACING
ITS COUNTY FACING IT COMES
TOGETHER -- WIT WITH ALL OF THE
THE PARTNERSHIPS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR INPUT ON THAT.
THROUGH NOT JUST THE
IMPLEMENTATION STAGE BUT THE
PLANNING STAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
STAGE AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
STAGE SO.
APPRECIATE THAT STAFF IS CLEARLY
LAID OUT THE OBJECTIVES IN KEY
FINDINGS -- FROM THE REPORT THAT
WE DID.
OUR AND WE DO INTEND TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE PROCEED GOING
FORWARD.
AS WE GO FORWARD THE CLIENT
FACING NATURE OF THIS KIND OF
STUFF THAT THE COUNTY BENEFITING
NATURE OF THE STUFF IT'S BOTH
GOOD FOR PEOPLE AND GOOD FOR
GOVERNMENT.
AND WE THINK IT WOULD BE A LOST
OPPORTUNITY NOT TO PURSUE IT.
I HAVE BEEN ANSWER QUESTIONS I
TRY TO BE BRIEF.
THANK YOU I KNOW THERE WILL BE
QUESTIONS NEXT WITNESS.
TYLER WAS PERMANENT FINANCE
NOTHING HAD.
BRENT METZ CARELLI -- NO
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM.
THE LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE HUB.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MECCA WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF THE AGENCIES THAT ADMINISTER
THESE PROGRAMS ON YOUR BEHALF.
WE LARGELY CONCUR WITH WHAT MR
CHIPPING CAST SAID ABOUT.
THE VALUE IN LOOKING AT AN
APPLICATION HOW TO SIMPLIFY THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS FOR CLIENTS
AND FOR WORKERS -- AND IT'S NOT
GOOD GOVERNMENT AS WELL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AND WE JUST
MAKE A NOTE.
THE THE RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
THE CONSULTANT TO TO DELAY.
OUT TWO YEARS SIX THROUGH TEN
THE INCORPORATION OF SAWS INTO
WHAT MIGHT BE A NEW APPLICATION
HUB.
IS SOMETHING WE'D LIKE MORE
DISCUSSION OF BECAUSE WE SEE A
VALUE IN HAVING THAT INTEGRATION
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE ENTIRE
PROCESS.
THAT THE SMALL DETAIL I KNOW THE
ISSUE FOR TODAY IS SORT OF IS
THERE CONSENSUS THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO.
AND WE WOULD CAN CONCUR WE WOULD
CONCUR THAT THIS IS A VALUABLE
THING TO PURSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TRACY PATTERSON WITH
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
JUST SIMPLY WANT TO SAY WE THINK
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD PROJECT
AND WE SUPPORTED MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YES MISTER FRAZIER.
WE'VE HEARD TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THAT THE BUREAUCRACY.
ACTUALLY AFFECTS THE CONSUMER OF
THE CLIENT -- WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS IN DOING THIS IS
ESSENTIAL -- WERE IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND WE'RE STILL
USING METHODOLOGIES AND WE'RE
DONE AND IN.
BEFORE CHRIST.
SO SERIOUSLY ARMAND I MEAN.
LITERALLY SO WE'VE GOT A WE'VE
GOT A STEP UP WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
BETTER WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
I AGREE.
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
AFTER THAT WHO WANTS.
TO I WOULD LIKE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER REPORTING LANGUAGE
ASKING AUTOMATION PROJECTS TO
SUMMARIZE AND COMMUNICATE.
HOW CURRENT PROJECT DEVELOPMENTS --
MEETING THE TECHNICAL AND
NONTECHNICAL RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE ROAD MAP THAT WE'VE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
SPECIFYING A SEMI ANNUAL DATE BY
WHICH THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
SHARED WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
I WILL ASK STAFF TO WORK ON THIS
IN PREPARATION TO CLOSE OUT AND
MAY.
COMMENTS ANY OF ANYTHING ELSE.
ALL RIGHT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS I WE WANTED TO TAKE
THIS FIRST.
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS NO
PROPOSAL HERE BUT I THINK IF IT
SETS THE THE THE THE FOUNDATION
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE WE'RE GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT -- YOU'RE
RIGHT WE DO NEED A HUB WE NEED
TO HAVE SOMETHING TO CENTRALIZE
ALL OF THE INFORMATION TO
STREAMLINED IT IS MISTER FRAZIER
WHOSE AS INDICATED
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE PACKETS IN
PACKETS TO GIVE TO PEOPLE WHEN
THEY APPLY.
FOR THE PROGRAM.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT TO THEY WERE MOVED TO
BACK.
TO ISSUE NUMBER
.
TWO OKAY HELLO HELLO I'M CYNTHIA
TUCKER WITH THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION AND I'M
JOINED BY MY TO PROGRAM SPONSORS --
FROM DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES JIM NIGHT AND FROM THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
ANASTASIA DOTSON -- WANTED JUST
BRING FORWARD THAT THE
INFORMATION THE AGENDA IS.
IS VERY WELL WRITTEN IS FOR WITH
HER CROSSED US PHASE ONE AND
PHASE -- TWO WANTED TO I WAS AT
WE WERE ASKED TO BE ABLE TO KIND
OF SPEAK TO HOW THE THE TO WORK
TOGETHER YOU MIGHT SAY -- EBV
HAS AN EFFECT ACROSS FIVE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTAL PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
SO.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT BCP
IS FOCUSED ON THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM
WHICH IS -- MANAGER OPERATED BY
AT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND IT FOCUSES ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MODIFICATIONS
NEEDED FOR THE SAME SYSTEM.
THE SECOND PIECE THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER IS FOCUSED ON AT
ALL OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS
CDA DDS DH CS IN CD PH -- WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT -- AN AGENCY
WIDE MODEL FOR EBV
IMPLEMENTATION -- SO.
INSTEAD YOU LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING.
ANASTASIA DOESN'T PERMIT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMING
MONTHS.
AS WE EXAMINE THE OPTIONS AND
DEVELOP A RECOMMENDED APPROACH
AND WILL CERTAINLY KEEP YOUR
STAFF IN THE LOOP ON WONDERFUL
THANK YOU.
IT JIM NIGHT WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DON'T HAVE IT AT AND TO
BE BACK ON WHAT THE STOCKTON
SAID IS THAT.
A KEY COMPONENT OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS THAT -- RESOURCES TO HELP
COORDINATE THE STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT OBVIOUSLY THE SYNTAX
SEVERAL THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO
IN SOME CASES YOU SERVICES FROM
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE
CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE INPUT AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH WITH FOLKS NOT
ONLY RECEIVE SERVICE BUT BUT
THOSE WHO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
AS WELL TO HELP INFORM THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STEPHEN PUBLIC BERMAN FINANCE
WOULD NOT BEEN AT BRENT METZ
CORELLIA WE REVIEWED THIS
PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN IT TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MACKESY TO BE D. A. R. MEMBERS
EMPLOY THE SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES PROGRAM AND
ADMINISTER THAT PROGRAM.
SHE ATE THE EFFORTS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE EBV
IMPLEMENTATION AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CLIENTS IN
PROVIDERS ARE GOING TO HAVE
DIFFICULTIES AND WHEN THEY DO
THEY CONTACT THEIR SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR ASSISTANCE AND ADDS
THIS PROPOSAL DEVELOPS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE IMPACT ON THE SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THE SYSTEM IS
ACCOUNTED FOR SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE TO
CLIENTS AND PROVIDERS THAT DON'T
NEED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPRING TO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WHAT I WANT TO JUST OF FOR
CLARIFICATION?
THIS SPRING OF FINANCE LETTER IS
ASKING FOR RESOURCES LARGELY FOR
PHASE TWO OF THIS DVD IT IS.
YES YES MA'AM IT'S FOCUSED ON
FACE TO AND IT'S REALLY TO BEGIN
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
SO -- WE'VE DONE A BUSINESS
ANALYSIS WE ARE NOW ABOUT TO
KICK OFF -- STAGE GET TO WHICH
IS THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS DH
CS AND DS -- WILL BE LEADING ALL
OF THE FIVE DEPARTMENTS IN THAT
ANALYSIS TO SEE HOW EXISTING
SYSTEMS OR AN EXISTING -- ITEMS
THAT PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY USING
CAN BE LEVERAGED -- AT IN ORDER
TO DETERMINE WHAT A RECOMMENDED
SOLUTION FOR THIS IS AGENCY WIDE --
EFFORT SHOULD BE THAT FITS.
WITH ALL THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALREADY THERE
[inaudible]
WONDERFUL.
GIVEN THE UPDATED COST THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK FOR UPDATED COMPREHENSIVE
TOTAL PROJECT.
COSTS ACROSS FISCAL YEARS. ONE
WOULD BE REASONABLE.
TO RECEIVE THESE BY THE END OF
THE WEEK BY NEXT WEEK WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC PROJECT COST
BECAUSE IN THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO
PROJECT YET.
WE DO HAVE -- HIGH LEVEL
PLANNING COSTS THAT UP THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING OVER.
A COURSE OF COMPLETING THE PAL
THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS WAS A
TO ALTURAS ANALYSIS IS REALLY
THE END OF THAT AND THAT
APPROVAL.
REALLY THEN FORMULATES WHAT THE
PROJECT COST IN TIME WHEN WOULD
LOOK LIKE SO WE'RE WE'RE A BIT
AWAYS FROM BEING ABLE TO GIVE
YOU THE THE EXTENSIVE PROJECT
COSTS.
WELL I WOULD ASK THAT THIS BE
SHARED WITH STAFF -- EVEN IF
IT'S JUST THE HIGH LEVEL PROJECT
COSTS. TO DO THAT FOR US PLEASE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU I THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION.
IT WILL BE HELD OPEN
[inaudible]
ISSUE
THREE SOME.
THANK YOU I LIKE BOTH OF YOU
JUST I LIKE IT JUST BOOM BOOM
YOU KNOW THAT I'M DONE -- OF
COURSE AND JOIN WITH BUY A PEEP
TRIMMING GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL SERVICES AND RENEE
MAILLOT FROM DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
ONCE AGAIN THE WHAT'S BEEN LAID
OUT BY STAFF.
COMPLETELY EXPLAINS THE THE
PROPOSAL AND SO I WAS WONDERING
IF THERE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO THIS PROPOSAL --
THAT AREN'T ALREADY LAID OUT.
I KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE EASIEST
WAY TO DO IT BUT I'D LIKE TO DO
NOT BLOCK COMMENT FIRST YEAH SO
IF YOU'LL JUST TWO BRIEF
PRESENTATION -- SO THE MEDS
MODERNIZATION OP EFFORT -- IS
TOO MUCH NONE THE LESS I THANK
YOU -- FOR FOR SAYING SUCH
WONDERFUL THINGS ABOUT STAFF
YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS.
IT IS SO SO NICELY DONE.
OKAY SO -- THE MEDS
MODERNIZATION EFFORT IS A MULTI
DEPARTMENTAL EFFORT TO TAKE THE
MEDS SYSTEM WHICH STORES --
ELIGIBILITY DATA IN REGARDS TO
AND NUMEROUS -- PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS ACROSS -- MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IT HAS -- LAID ON TOP OF OR
SORRY THAT IT'S MADE FROM REALLY
GOES BACK TO THE EARLY SEVENTIES --
IT WAS ORIGINALLY IMPLEMENTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I BELIEVE.
AND SO THAT WAS HARD TO BELIEVE
WHAT I READ THE YEAH WE'RE A
LITTLE YOU KNOW.
WE'RE A LITTLE OUT OF DATE --
THOUGH THAT THE SYSTEM RUNS VERY
WELL -- AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
BUT IT'S NOT FLEXIBLE WITH
REGARDS TO SOME OF THE INTER
OPERABILITY IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING OUT FOR CROSS PROGRAMS
ACROSS STATE -- WHEN IT COMES --
TO YOU KNOW INTERACTIVITY.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
WITH THIS EFFORT IS TO TAKE BY
FACE STARTING WITH THE HEALTH
INFORMATION SYSTEM.
UP WHICH IS A SUBSET OF THE OF
THE MEDS AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
MODERNIZE THE FIRST WE'RE DOING
THE MODERNIZATION AND FOR FACE
EFFORT THAT WILL BE MULTI YEAR --
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THIS IS
WE WANT TO A DO SOME LEARNING --
AS WERE DOING MODULAR NOT ONLY
THAT BUT E WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MOVING METHODICALLY
UNDERSTANDING TO MINIMIZE THE
LAST THING WE WANT IS ANY IMPACT
BENEFICIARIES AS WORKS MOVING.
UP INFORMATION OR INNER
CONNECTIVE ITTY WITH THE SIZE
AND CAL HERE'S AS ARE
MODERNIZING AT NOT ONLY THAT WE
WANT TO REDUCE IMPACT FOR COUNTY
WORKERS WHO VERY MUCH RELY
HEAVILY ON THE MEDS -- FOR A
NUMBER OF FAIR.
BUSINESS PROCESS SEES.
SO THAT'S KIND OF IT OF THE HIGH
LEVEL.
UNNAMED BUT IN A CURRENT PIECE
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW WE ARE INTO
PROCUREMENT TO GET OUR FIRST --
DEVELOPMENT VENDOR SO THAT WE
CAN START WORKING ON H. I. S.
BOTH DATA CONVERSION AS WELL AS
AT BUILDING OUT.
OF START THE BUILDING OUT OF THE
METS MODERNIZATION.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
PICTURE BANCO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WERE WERE ONE OF
THE MAIN USERS OTHER THAN DH CS
IN THE SYSTEM WERE HUGELY
INTERESTED IN THIS BEING A
SUCCESS AND AND MODERNIZING
PROVIDING THE CAPABILITY IS
THERE.
WELL WHAT'S STARTING IN THE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR DOESN'T
NECESSARILY AFFECT US DIRECTLY
IN TERMS OF HEALTH INFORMATION
SYSTEMS -- IT'S ABSOLUTELY VITAL
THAT THAT WE BE INVOLVED AND
IT'S BEEN A GREAT PARTNERSHIP AS
AS WE THINK OF AND PLAN AHEAD.
FOR FOR WHAT THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO
DO HOW ITS ARCHITECTED WHAT ITS
FUNCTIONALITIES WILL BE AND
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE PART
OF THE EFFORT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RENE MAILLOT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND I JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
JUST TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WITH.
THIS SYSTEM IT IS USED BY THE
MEDIC HOW PROGRAM NOT JUST FOR
PURPOSES OF ELIGIBILITY BUT ALSO
HELPING PROVIDERS TO KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE PRESENT IN OUR OFFICES.
IF INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE AS
WELL AS TO ASSIST WITH PAYMENT
FOR SERVICES IN THE MEDICAL PARK
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS OP PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
AND I WILL OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT -- I'M SORRY.
WE HAVE MORE IMPORTANT WITNESSES
[inaudible]
NOT.
AND BRIAN METZGER LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS PROJECT PROPOSALS
STILL GOING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE WHICH
IS THE STATE'S IT PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS.
AND THE PROJECT ANTICIPATES
COMPLETING THAT PROCESS BY
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY AND SO
THIS PROPOSES A LITTLE BIT
UNIQUE -- IN THAT SOME OF THE
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES THAT YOU HEARD
MENTIONED AROUND H. I GUESS WERE
ALLOWED IN PARALLEL TO THAT
PLANNING PROCESS AND SO --
THAT'S GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO
PILOT DEVELOPMENT ENVIRONMENTS
TO KIND OF BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE PROJECT
AS WELL TO KIND OF USE H. I. S.
AS A PROOF OF CONCEPT FOR THE
APPROACH GOING FORWARD -- WE
GENERALLY AGREE WITH THAT
APPROACH THIS IS A PRETTY
COMPLEX AND SIZEABLE PROJECT --
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IN
THE PROPOSAL THERE ARE THERE IS
A REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR OTHER
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO FACE -- TO
THAT ARE COMING IN ADVANCE OF
COMPLETING THE PLANNING PROCESS --
WERE ALSO CONCERNED A BIT ABOUT
BEING ASKED TO APPROVE FOR YOUR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING GIVEN THAT
AT THE END OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE WILL HAVE A
MORE COMPLETE PROJECT PLAN THAT
INCLUDES.
A FIRM BASE LINE IN THE COSTS GO
BEEN SCHEDULED THE PROJECT GOING
FORWARD AND SO WE MIGHT YOU KNOW
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
LEGISLATURE MIGHT ASK THE
ADMINISTRATIONTO EXPLAIN.
HOW THE BUDGET YOU'RE FUNDING
FOR PHASE -- TWO IS GOING TO BE
USED AND WHY IT'S NECESSARY IN
THIS CURRENT PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
TO ASK -- HOW THE FOR YOUR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSAL WILL BE USED -- GIVEN
THE LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE A
COMPLETE PROJECT PLAN SO WITH
THAT I'LL LEAVE IT THERE.
THANK YOU WELL THERE'S YOUR
FIRST QUESTION.
I THINK -- ONE OF THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO DO AND WORKING
WITH WORKING WITH THE ART
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND WITH
MOVING -- PHASE ONE OR HAVING
FACE WILL BE PART OF THE PROCESS
BOB OUR GOAL IN A REQUEST AND
ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR PHASE TWO
AS WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE A
DELAY -- FROM PHASE ONE PHASE
TWO BEGINNING WE HAVE A CONTRACT
ON BOARD WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE --
KNOWLEDGE BASE BECAUSE IF WE IF
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR FURTHER WORK
WE WOULD END UP LOSING CONTRACT
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
H. I. AFTER THE METS
MODERNIZATION.
SO IT'S REALLY TO STREAMLINE --
ALL OF THE RESOURCES BOTH STATE
AND CONTRACTOR SO THAT WE CAN
JUST CONTINUE AND JUST KEEP
MOVING IN WITH THAT APPROVAL
SORT WORKING WITH C. T. ON HOW
DO WE MINIMISE -- SO HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE MINIMISE THE TIME
PHASE ONE AND PHASE TWO BEGINS
AND SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
THROUGH WHAT OF THOSE CRITERIA
IS ONE OF THOSE CHECKPOINTS.
MONTHLY OR BI WEEKLY WHATEVER
THEY NEED TO BE ALL THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
A LARGE APPROVAL.
PROCESS AT THE END THAT IT'S
MUCH MORE STREAMLINED WE CAN
MOVE AS QUICKLY AS EFFECTIVELY
INTO -- FACE.
TO THAT IS OUR GOAL.
AND THE REASON WHY IT HAS SOME
OF THE IT HAS SOME OF THE SPACE
TO COST IN HERE.
IT IT TO ADDRESS THE THE ISSUE
FROM LA -- IS OUR LANGUAGE THAT
CAN BE PUT IN SO THAT THERE ARE
THOSE CHECK POINTS AND THAT IS
REVIEWED.
AND A TIMELY BASIS I UNDERSTAND
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
STREAMLINE IT -- SO THAT THERE
ISN'T A GAP IN THE FUNDING -- IT
TO TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF ELIO
CAN THERE BE -- THOSE
CHECKPOINTS. TO USE YOUR PHRASE
I THINK YOU WERE WORKING WITH
CITY YES -- YES WE CAN DO THAT
WE HAVE WORKING WITH DIGNITY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT WOULD BE --
TO IN SHORT TRANSPARENCY. FOR
BELIEVE SOMEBODY WANTS TO ADD
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RON ROBINETTE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
AND TO ADDRESS WHAT MR MASTERS
SAYING.
I'M THERE ARE CHECKS AND
BALANCES BUILT INTO THE PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS SAID THAT IF
THERE.
THE BUDGET FOR THIS EFFORT AND
SAT BEING. 20% OVER WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED OR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WHICHEVER IS
LESS THAN THERE WOULD BE A PAUSE
AND THAT DISCUSSION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND AND OTHERS.
ON WHAT THE NEXT STEPS FOR THE
PROJECT WOULD BE.
ADDITIONALLY SINCE THIS MONEY IS
CONSIDERED.
A PLANNING DOLLARS FOR THE
PROJECT THE PROJECT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A QUARTERLY
PROJECT EXPENDITURE REPORT. TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH WILL
OUTLINE HOW THEY'RE EXPENDING
THESE MONIES FOR THE PROJECT AS
WELL AS THAT THE FUTURE MONIES
FOR THE OVERALL PROJECT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I BRIAN METZGER LA -- APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS THIS BUILT IN CHECK
POINT OF THE FIVE MILLION OR 20%
WHICHEVER IS LESS -- BUT WE
WOULD STILL NOTE THAT THAT
LANGUAGE -- REFERENCES AN
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS THAT'S DONE
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
WOULD LIKE THAT ANALYSIS TO BE
SHARED WITH THE LEGISLATURE SO
THAT WE ARE AWARE.
OF WHAT CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE
IN THE PROJECT SCOPE SCHEDULER
COST TO BE ABLE TO BRING IT MORE
IN LINE WITH WHAT WAS ESTIMATED
REGIONALLY.
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO EL SKELLY --
TO HELP -- CRAFT THE LANGUAGE.
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
SO WE CAN SO WE CAN CAPTURE
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THAT -- LA
THOSE CONCERNS HAPPY TO DO SO.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NO.
NOW WILL OPEN IT UP TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I THINK WE HEARD FROM THE ONLY
PERSON IN THE PUBLIC THEM.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MISTER FRAZIER
THANK YOU.
SO.
IN A PREVIOUS CHAIRMANSHIP I WAS
THE CHAIR OF THE COUNT ABILITY
IN ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE.
AND WE DID HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY IN I THINK OF
CARLOS WAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
THAT POINT.
WE'VE HAD MANY IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROGRAMS IN DIFFERENT AGENCIES
THAT HAVE BEEN.
WHAT I WOULD SAY LESS THAN
SATISFACTORY?
WHAT ARE THE STOP GAP SAID HAVE
BEEN LEARNED AND PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT HAVE BEEN LEARNED --
SINCE THIS CAL [inaudible]
JUDICIARY [inaudible]
DMV.
I MEAN IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S BEEN
AN ONGOING LISTING YOU LOOK AT
THE MONIES IS GOING TO BE SPENT
HERE WHAT ASSURANCES WE HAVE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GONNA WORK I
SEE SOME INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION VALIDATION FROM
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT I'M SEEING.
ASSURANCES THAT THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO BE SPENT IN AN
APPROPRIATE FASHION.
THAT WE'VE LEARNED OUR LESSON
AND THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO
GO FORWARD SO THAT WE ACTUALLY
GET THE VALUE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING FOR BECAUSE IN THE PAST.
WE HAVEN'T.
AND THE ONLY ONE THERE TO GET
RIPPED OFF FOR THE TAXPAYERS.
SO CAN YOU SHOW ME THAT THE THAT
WE'VE LEARNED OUR LESSON WE'RE
GONNA GO IN ADVANCE AND WE'RE
GONNA ALSO REPORTS LEGISLATURE
AN APPROPRIATE FASHION.
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY WORKING
AND YOU YOUR MONEY THAT YOU'RE
SPENDING.
ABSOLUTELY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT IT THERE'S LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE LARGER PROJECTS
SMALLER PROJECTS LESSONS THAT WE
LEARNED WITH AND PROJECTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENTS -- A PSYCH
CETERA.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH CDG
THEY'VE ASKED BEEN ASKING US
QUESTIONS TO HELP US HONE ARE
PROOF OF CONCEPT -- AS WELL AS
TO ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
PROVIDE CYCLE IN ORDER -- TO
INSURE THAT ALL OF US ARE ASKING
THE APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS.
THIS PROOF OF CONCEPT THE WHOLE
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF HAVING THIS
IS PART OF THE POWER IS TO LEARN
AND SEE.
IS THE STRATEGY ARE THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE'VE MADE ARE
THEY ACCURATE DO THEY NEED TO BE
TWEAKED A BIT BEFORE WE HAVE AN
APPROVED PROJECTS SO OUR GOAL.
IS VERY MUCH IN ALIGNMENT WITH
YOURS WHICH IS TO ENSURE THAT WE
LEARN SOMETHING AND SAID THE
PROJECT OFF ON THE STRONGEST
FOOTING WE CAN'T -- SO.
IN THE IN THAT REGARD THAT
THAT'S THE INSURANCE I CAN GIVE
IS THAT THAT'S THE WORK WE'RE
DOING IS.
TO DO AS MUCH AS PROACTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT IS SUCCESSFUL AND I'M
NOT TRYING.
TO DIMINISH YOUR YOUR OF VIGOR.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD US
BEFORE.
THESE OTHER AGENCIES.
AND SO WHAT TO INSURANCE IS DO
WE HAVE.
THAT -- THERE ARE STOP GAP
MEASURES THAT.
THIS GOES FORWARD THEY'RE
PROBABLY FASHION DOESN'T GET
INTO.
A PROGRAMMING NIGHTMARE THAT
DOESN'T WORK FOR CERTAIN
AGENCIES THEN WE HAVE TO PUT
BANDAIDS ON AND THEN I HAVE TO
PUT MORE MONEY INTO IT.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE PAST.
AND THAT WE DON'T CONTINUE
WHAT'S THAT -- EINSTEIN THANK.
THE INSANITY.
YOU KNOW THE WE DON'T PERPETUATE
THAT DO THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER YEAH YEAH YEAH DEFINITION.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT.
I'LL BLOW MY TOP.
YOU KNOW SERIOUSLY WE'VE GOT A
WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S ALL I'M
SAYING.
SO AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH
YOU.
THE MEMBER FRAZIER IF I CAN
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY
ON SOME OF THE STOP GAPS AGAIN
RON ROBINETTE WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR THIS SPECIFIC
EFFORT -- THEY HAVE WENT THROUGH
THE RIGOR OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL BY CYCLE WHICH INCLUDES
A LOT MORE PLANNING MEASURES --
THAN THOSE OTHER PROJECTS IN THE
PAST.
VERY STAGE GATES THAT THEY'VE
HAD TO UP MATURE THROW IN THEIR
PLANNING EFFORT AND THEN WE'VE
TAKEN A SPECIAL APPROACH WITH
THIS PROJECT THAT YOU THAT
YOU'VE HEARD.
WERE WERE ALLOWING THIS PROOF OF
CONCEPT WHETHER STILL IN
PLANNING. TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT DOLLARS THAT ARE ASKED
FOR FOR THE ENTIRE EFFORT ARE
VALIDATED AND WE WE HAVE SOME
BASIS FOR THAT.
ADDITIONALLY ONCE THIS PROJECT
IS FORMALLY LAUNCHED -- IT WILL
REQUIRE MONTHLY A PROJECT STATUS
REPORTING FROM THE PROJECT AND
THEN ALSO DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY INDEPENDENT.
PROJECT OVERSIGHT REPORT WILL BE
DONE ON A MONTHLY BASIS BASIS.
IN ADDITION TO THE INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION AND VALIDATION THAT
WILL BE DONE WITH THE PROJECT SO
MANY REPORTS THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY INCLUDING TO
THE LEGISLATURE -- THAT WILL
GIVE YOU STATUS AND HOW THIS
PROJECT IS GOING.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND AND
AGAIN WE'VE WILL HOPEFULLY WE'VE
LEARNED FROM OUR PAST.
FULL PAUSE -- GOING FORWARD YEAH
IT LOOKS SO I LOOK FORWARD.
TO AN IMPLEMENTATION THAT IS.
OF NOT SO MUCH FOLLOW SANDERS
AND THERE CAN BE BUGS AND IN
EVERY.
IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT WHO'S GONNA BE RESPONSIBLE
THAT ISN'T.
WHO'S GOING OF THE WEATHER THE
BUCK STOPS [inaudible]
LOOKS.
YES I DID.
THROUGH WHERE DOES THE BUCK STOP
WHO DO I CONTACT.
BECAUSE I'M HERE FOR ANOTHER SIX
YEARS THIS PROJECT WILL BE.
UP AND RUNNING BY THEN I'D LIKE
TO KNOW WHO'S GONNA TAKE THE
WHO'S GONNA TAKE THE THE PLANET
DOESN'T OR THE CREDIT.
YEAH I LIKE THAT I LIKE THE
CREDIT PIECE -- OSI IS LEADING
THIS EFFORT IN REGARD IT WITH --
WITH -- ASSISTANCE WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT SO I THINK THE
STARTING POINT IS WITH US I
WOULD JUST READ CELL NUMBERS
OKAY.
THEY MIGHT CALL YOU RIGHT ON THE
DID YOU WANT TO PROVIDE.
I I I WOULD JUST ADD A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF SPECIFICS YOU KNOW
WE TALKED IT ALL ALREADY TODAY
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY A PUBLIC
REPORTING -- WE FOUND IN A
NUMBER OF THE PROJECTS THAT WE
RELY ON AT AT SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT ONE OF OUR OUR BEST --
PRACTICES IS TO INVOLVE THE
LEGISLATURE ON A QUARTERLY OR
SEMI ANNUAL BASIS WHERE WE OFFER
A BRIEFING TO STAFF SIT DOWN
TALK THROUGH WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THERE'S NO SURPRISES WITH THAT --
OTHER EFFORTS THAT WE'VE DONE --
SUCH AS CAL SAWS THAT WE'LL TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT LATER WE HAVE
AN ONGOING STAKEHOLDER MEETING
ALL OF THE MATERIALS FOR THOSE
MEETINGS ALL THE DISCUSSIONS THE
NOTES.
ARE PUBLICLY POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE AT TRANSPARENCY GOES A
LONG WAY TO LA OWES POINT ABOUT
FOR YOUR LIMITED TERM POSITIONS --
I KNOW IS AT MY DEPARTMENT
ALTHOUGH WE ASK FOR LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES WE DON'T MAKE LIMITED
TERM JOB OFFERS TO PEOPLE WE
MAKE PERMANENT JOB OFFERS
BECAUSE WE NEED THE STABILITY ON
THE PROJECT I CAN'T COME BACK
EVERY TWO YEARS.
AND AND TELL YOU WELL THE PERSON
I GAVE IT TO YOUR JOB OFFER TO
KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO LOSE IT
SO THEY TOOK ANOTHER ONE SIX
MONTHS AGO.
I CAN'T RUN A PROJECT LIKE NOT
SO STABILITY IN PROJECT
LEADERSHIP IS IMPORTANT -- YOU
KNOW BACK TO WHERE I STARTED
WITH ABOUT ENGAGEMENT IN
TRANSPARENCY IF THERE ARE
PARTICULAR ITEMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONCERNED THAT WE
MIGHT NOT BE THINKING ABOUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THAT BACK TO
NOT JUST US TELLING YOU.
WHERE WE'RE AT BUT ALSO?
HEARING FROM YOU.
YOU CLEARLY HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE
WITH IT PROJECTS WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESSES SEE MAPS TO IS A
SUCCESS NOT BE T. TRANSITION AS
AS WE DO DO THINGS RIGHT AND WE
TRY TO LEARN FROM THOSE AS WELL.
STARTING SMALL THE PROOF OF
CONCEPT BIKE IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WE START WITH A
SMALL PIECE OF IT TO SEE IF IT'S
ACTUALLY GONNA WORK AND WE FAIL
CHEAPLY IN EARLY -- AS OPPOSED
TO HERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SEE YOU IN FOUR YEARS
AND COME BACK TO US AND WE'LL
SEE IF IT WORKS -- YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THOSE KINDS OF APPROACHES
DON'T WORK USER CENTERED DESIGN
IS IN OUR JEFF.
ANYWAY THE POINT B. AND IF YOU
HAVE A LIST OF THINGS THAT ARE
OF PARTICULAR CONCERN WE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THAT EARLY ON IN
OUR PLANNING PROCESS IT WOULD
WELCOME THAT DIALOGUE IS THERE
ANY FORM OF PEER REVIEW
COMMITTEE AS THE PROCESS GOES ON
WE FOUND IN LARGER.
PROJECTS THAT WHEN YOU INTEGRATE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH.
SAVE ON DUTY AND YOUR AGENCY
PROFESSIONALS THAT WHEN THERE'S
A PEER REVIEW COMMITTEE THAT
ACTUALLY CAN COME THROUGH AND
SAY -- THE AND VALIDATE LIKE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT AT THE
STOP GAP.
BONUS -- UNBIASED ON A BASH TO
READY TO GO WITH THE INFORMATION
AND YOU KNOW.
IS THERE ANY KIND OF OF PURPOSE
OR ANY COMMITTEE LIKE THAT
APPEAR REVIEW COMMITTEE I I I
WOULD ANSWER IT THIS WAY THE HHS
AGENCY IS A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE.
THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION IN OUR AGENCY
ACTUALLY KIND OF PERFORMS THAT
FUNCTION BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
PROJECT MANAGER ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE PROJECT SO THEY HAVE THE
VISIBILITY TO THAT.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO OUTSIDE
VENDORS LIKE IVY ENVY OR THE
INDEPENDENT PROJECT OVERSIGHT
CONSULTANTS THAT WE TALKED AYE
POCK THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SO
WE HAVE A COMBINATION OF THOSE
THINGS.
WHEN WE HIRE A VENDOR WE DON'T?
KIND OF PAY THEM PUT THEM IN A
ROOM AND NOT TALK TO THEM YOU
KNOW THAT'S LIKE ARE WE WILL IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING MAKES SENSE HOW
WOULD YOU DO IT.
WE'RE INCREASINGLY TRYING TO
DEFINE THE OUTCOME OF WHAT WE
WANT TO ACHIEVE AND NOT DEFINED
THE HOW YOU HAVE TO GET THEIR
WHICH IMPOSES A LIMIT AND ALLOWS
THAT CREATIVE THINKING AND THE
TWO WAY DIALOGUE.
SO THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING CAN WE GUARANTEE
SUCCESS OF COURSE NOT.
CAN WE GUARANTEE TRANSPARENCY
INTO A CLEAR DISCUSSION OF
ISSUES AS THEY ARISE AND BEST
EFFORTS TO RESOLVE THEM
ABSOLUTELY.
AND PARTICULARLY ON THE LARGE
PROJECTS THAT YOU'RE HEARING
ABOUT TODAY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR ADEQUATE STATE STAFF SUPPORT.
FOR WE FOUND THAT WHERE WERE
UNDER RESOURCE AND DON'T HAVE
THE SKILL SETS IS EXACTLY WHERE
THE PROBLEMS COME UP.
RIGHT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR AND YOUR
SUPPORT AND I'LL DO IT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOU RECOGNIZING THAT.
REVIEWS IS.
IMPORTANT PART OF THE YES
ABSOLUTELY IT IS THANKS.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK AND WE TOOK
THE APPLICATION HUB FIRST FOR A
REASON LIKE I DO WANT TO TO
EXPLAIN.
HOW THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE
APPLICATION HUB?
ARE INFLUENCING THE DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT -- AND IT'S BOND --
YEAH BARBARA WHO WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT FIRST YEAR [inaudible]
OF THE FOR FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
ALTHOUGH AS MISS SMALL INDICATED
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF THINGS
MEDS DOES THERE'S ACTUALLY I
THINK A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
HUNDRED EIGHTY DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
THAT MET AND FOUGHT AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND FUNCTIONS THAT
MEDS INTEROPERATES WITH.
SO IT'S A FAIRLY COMPLEX SYSTEM --
IT. FOR OUR PROGRAMS.
IT'S VERY OFTEN THE THE SYSTEM
OF RECORD -- WHETHER SOMEBODY'S
BEEN ON AID WHICH AID CODES
THEY'VE BEEN AND AND AND SO WE
USE THAT IN OUR ELIGIBILITY
PROCESS SEES.
I THAT INPUT IS PROVIDED. TO THE
MADS LARGELY FROM US -- AND AND
IT'S A LOOKUP FUNCTION FOR US.
SO THERE'S A LITTLE BIT LESS IN
TERMS OF THE APPLICATION HARD
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE SYSTEM THAT
ACTIVELY FOR US DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY ITS RECORDING
ELIGIBILITY.
OVER TIME IN THE PROGRAM BLESS
YOU THANK YOU.
AND ACROSS MULTIROTOR CROSS
MULTIPLE PROGRAM SO THE FUNCTION
IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FOR US
THE HUB IS MOSTLY CENTERED
AROUND THE SAUCE SYSTEMS WHICH
FOR MEDI CAL CAL FRESH -- I KEEP
SAYING TEN F. BUT IT'S CAL WORKS --
AND A VARIETY OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS -- DEBT.
THE SAWS IS THE SYSTEM THAT'S
PROCESSING ELIGIBILITY THAT WILL
BENEFIT THE MOST FROM FROM THE
HARM.
BUT THE CLIENT CENTERED FOCUS
ARE WE GETTING WHAT WE NEED WHEN
I THINK OF MADS AND I THINK OF
THE THE COUNTY USER FROM MY
DEPARTMENTS PERSPECTIVE IT'S THE
COUNTY USER THAT'S THE CLIENT.
AND ARE THEY ABLE TO GET WHAT
THEY WANT RIGHT NOW FOR EXAMPLE
A LOT OF THE FUNCTIONALITY WE
NEED IS OVERNIGHT BATCH
PROCESSING.
SO THEY CAN'T ALWAYS GET AN
ANSWER WHEN THE CLIENT SITTING
IN FRONT OF THEM.
AND THEY'RE DOING THE BEST THAT
WE CAN IN AT THE MOMENT IN TIME.
THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF WE WANT
TO CHANGE AND A HOBBY IN REAL
TIME ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION
WILL HELP.
MODERNIZING MADS PUTTING ON A
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS REAL TIME
WILL BE OF ASSISTANCE TO US.
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU LIKE THE
HUB IS GOING TO DRAMATICALLY
CHANGE THE MEDS BUT THE
PRINCIPLE OF OUR USERS GETTING
WHAT THEY WANT IS WHAT I WOULD.
TELL YOU IS A CONNECTION I I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
ADD.
THE ONLY OTHER THING I'D ADD IS
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE SYSTEMS ACROSS THE BOARD WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE.
TO AS WE WERE WORKING ON THE
DEVELOPMENT TAKE THE PICTURE.
INTO CONSIDERATION BECAUSE WE
HAVE MAD WE HAVE THE
VERIFICATION HAVE WE HAVE THE
SAWS WE HAVE CAL HEARERS AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS IN A
WORLD VALUE FOR ALL OF THOSE
SYSTEMS.
BUT WE ALSO MEANT WE THEN HAVE
TO LOOK AT FOR THE BIG PICTURE
PERSPECTIVE HOW THEY ALL WORK
TOGETHER AT THE END OF THE DAY.
MADS IS THAT DATA REPOSITORY
SYSTEM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HOUSES ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
DO ANY MODERNIZATION EFFORTS
THAT THOSE SYSTEMS THAT THEN
FEED INTO A MAN'S HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE IN OUR FACES.
OUR SYSTEM DESIGNED THAT WILL
HELP -- TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TRANSMIT DATA BACK
AND FORTH AND WHEN THERE'S
POLICY CHANGES WE HAVE TO THEN
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES IN
A SEAMLESS AND EFFICIENT WAY SO
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT HAVING TO
WAIT MONTHS ON THE AND FOR A NEW
POLICY TO GOING TO A FACT.
AS WE MODERNIZE THE SYSTEMS THEN
WE CAN MAKE CHANGES IN THE
SYSTEMS MORE IN REAL TIME MORE
QUICKLY.
THAN WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO TODAY
JUST BECAUSE OF THE OLD
TECHNOLOGY THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE
SITTING ON THANK YOU.
IT'S HARD IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
WE DON'T HAVE SUCH A SYSTEM
ALREADY RIGHT AFTER ALL THESE
YEARS -- BUT IT'S SO PROMISING
TO HEAR THAT WE'RE MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION.%
AND THAT WE REALLY WILL HAVE A
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM THE WHOLE OF
THE THE THE METS THE METS MON --
IT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT I
I THINK THAT BECAUSE IT IS SUCH
A COMPLEX CHANGE.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ALL
COMPLETELY INTEGRATED WE DO NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE?
THERE WILL BE LOTS OF HICK UPS
AS MISTER FRAZIER -- SAID -- I I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK AS A ASKED
EARLIER.
OF FOR UPDATES COMPREHENSIVE
TOTAL PROJECT.
ACOSTA CROSS FISCAL YEARS GIVEN
THIS NEW SPRING -- FINANCE
LETTER OF THE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW IS THE
RESPONSE THE SAME THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE PROJECT COST CORRECT WORK
SO YOU HAVE SOME PAL WILL HAVE
HIGH LEVEL.
PLANNING WHAT WE KNOW THROUGH
WORKING ON SUBSEQUENT
INFORMATION THAT WILL GET FINE
TUNED AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
PHASE ONE IT'LL FINE TUNE THE
PROJECT COST AND TIME LINE --
FOR CG APPROVAL.
THE I WOULD ASK THAT THIS HIGH
LEVEL -- COSTS.
REPORTING BE SHARED WITH STAFF
NOT A PROBLEM.
AND THE LA ILL.
MANAGER.
YES FRAZIER JUST TO IF YOU COULD
WHEN YOU DO ANTICIPATE OR HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE TOTAL
PROJECT COST.
DO YOU HAVE ANY KIND OF
CONCEPTUAL IDEA WHEN THAT MIGHT
BE A I'M NOT TO HOLD YOU TO IT
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY WHEN.
THE WHEN ADAM.
WHEN H. I. S. WHEN THE FIRST
PHASE IS DONE IT WILL WE ARE
GOING TO BE UPDATING --
FINISHING OUR COSTS ARE BASED
INVESTMENT AS WELL AS FINE
TUNING IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THE
THE F. A..
IS THE FINANCIAL THE FISCAL NOW
THIS WORKSHEETS THAT REQUIRED
FOR THE PROJECT THAT WILL THEN
TELL WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING THAT
THE TOTAL PROJECT COST TO BE.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT SPRING.
OKAY THERE AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S
BIT DEPENDENT YEAH I THINK WE'D
BE REMISS THE STATE NOT TO STATE
THE OBVIOUS [inaudible]
YEAH.
IT BIT DEPENDENT SORRY WHEN WE
GO OUT TO BID AND VENDORS ARE
THAT'S THEIR PROPOSALS
[inaudible]
WONDERFUL WE YEAH [inaudible]
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
ANYTHING FURTHER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR LOOKING
FORWARD TO GREAT THINGS.
THAT'S TRUE.
YES.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
ELIGIBILITY IN RETENTION SYSTEM
CAL HERE'S GOOD LUCK THE ONE I
MAY CALL YOU.
WELCOME MR DAWKINS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH I AM DAVE SECONDS WITH I'M
WITH THE OFFICE ASSISTANT
INTEGRATION.
AND I AM THE CAL HERE'S PROJECT
DIRECTOR.
AND CAME HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE WITH IT
CALPERS PROJECT TODAY.
SO RIGHT NOW WE ARE.
WE JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU LOOK UP
BACKGROUND WITHOUT HERE'S HOW
HERE'S IS THE SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORTS THE AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE ACT FOR THE CITY
CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE OFF THE
SYSTEM INTEGRATION RUNS AT
PROJECT ON BEHALF OF TWO
SPONSORS COVER CALIFORNIA IN
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
WE ARE ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM
INTEGRATOR CONTRACT.
FROM WHAT THE NEST SIDE.
IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWELVE WE
IMPLEMENTED IT WENT LIVE WITH
THE PROJECT ON OCTOBER OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN IN FIFTEEN MONTHS.
SO WE SUCCESSFULLY WENT THROUGH
SEVEN YEARS OF THAT CONTRACT.
AND WE ARE NOW ENTERING OUR
ENGINE WILL BE ENTERING OUR
EIGHTH AND FINAL YEAR OF THAT
CONTRACT.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN NEGOTIATIONS
ON FOR REPORT CHAIRMAN OF THE
DEVELOPMENT AND MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION.
INTEGRATOR.
AND WE ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE.
WE HAVE A POSSIBILITY THAT WE
MAY HAVE TO CONTRACTORS -- FOR
FOR WHILE IF WE HAVE A CHANGE IF
WE CHANGE CONTRACTORS.
YES SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL BUDGET
AUTHORITY TO COVER THAT FINAL
YEAR SO WE PLAN TO HAVE.
A CONTRACTOR BUT IN PLACE.
BY JUNE.
THAT'S THE TARGET.
AND WE WILL NEED TO DO --
TRANSITION AND WE LIKE TO HAVE
THE YEARS TRANSITION AND SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE DISH NO
BUDGET AUTHORITY TO COVER TO
CONTRACTORS AT THE TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LARA YEAH LEAD TO PERMANENT
FINANCE NOTHING ELSE AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RYAN METZGER LA -- WE HAVE NO
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOT BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
THERE'S A RANGE -- OF BIDS FROM
QUALIFYING VENDORS THAT RANGE
BETWEEN ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION AND THAT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL SEEMS THE
HIGHEST ESTIMATED COST FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE
[inaudible]
DULY NOTED.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
THE PUBLIC.
SAYING IN HEARING NO COMMENTS.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT -- CAN YOU INVITE
ADVISES HIGH LEVEL -- HOW YOU
THINK ABOUT -- HOW CAL HERE'S
RELATES TO MAD SMOG AND KELSO'S
HOW TO THE INTERFACE?
WHAT WE HAVE INTERFACE WITH BOTH
OF THOSE SYSTEMS I AM WELL WHAT
WHAT THE CAP WITH THE SAUCE
SYSTEMS AND BAD SMOG SYSTEM?
AND WE WE WORK WITH THEM AS AS
WE ARE DEVELOPMENT WE MAKE SURE
THAT -- AS WE DO OUR DEVELOPMENT
WHERE WE WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE INTERFACES ARE TESTED AND
THEY WORK PROPERLY [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE LA --
DO YOU SEE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING NO WE
REVIEWED THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE AS PART OF REVIEWING
THE PROPOSAL HAVE NO CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO EL SAME AS WITH
THE OTHERS -- FOR AN UPDATED
HOLISTIC FISCAL FISCAL PICTURE
FROM CAL HERE'S ARE GIVEN THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
SO IT IF YOU HAVE UPDATES ON
PROJECT COSTS.
I WOULD LOVE ELSE THAT THOSE BE
SHARED WITH STAFF.
YES DO THAT.
VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT NO OTHER QUESTIONS
THEN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.%
ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEMS.
NOW WE'RE DOWN SAWS.
AWARE OF CELLS.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS DUDLEY
AND I'M WITH THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
AND THIS IS THE CAL SAWS
PROPOSAL -- AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
CONSOLIDATING THREE SYSTEMS INTO
ONE TO MEET ARE FEDERALLY
MANDATED TIME FRAME OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND THERE IS ALSO A
SPRING FINANCE LETTER FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR THE
THREE DEPARTMENT CDSS DH CS ON
OUR SIDE -- AN EXPANDED ROLE FOR
THE STATE PROGRAM DEPARTMENTS
AND OUR SITE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CAL SAWS -- I HI AGAIN WOULD
SAY THAT YOU HAVE A GOOD SUMMARY
IN THE DOCUMENT AND IF THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OVERALL I'D GO ON
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA.
CENTER RIGHT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE FINE
UNLESS SOMEBODY FROM WE HEAR
SOMETHING FROM THE PUBLIC BUT
THAT WOULD BE FINE.
OKAY THE FIRST QUESTION WAS
ABOUT THE STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
HOW THAT IS GOING AN UPDATE ON
THAT TO AND MEASURES TO ENSURE
CONTINUED.
ENGAGEMENT AND I WOULD AY THAT
THE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS IS WELL UNDER WAY.
AND FROM A STATE PERSPECTIVE
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS THEY'VE
BEEN THREE LARGE GROUP QUARTERLY
MEETINGS AND THEN SEVERAL OTHER
SMALLER.
MEETINGS WITH A CORE GROUP OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY.
ARE CURRENTLY SCHEDULED ARE
CONTINUING QUARTERLY STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS FOR STATUS UPDATES AND
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON VARIOUS
TOPICS WE'VE ALSO STARTED
SCHEDULING MONTHLY IN DEPTH --
MEETINGS ON SPECIFIC TOPICS OF
INTEREST IN PARTICULAR.
AND THEN ALSO THE STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN --
PROCUREMENTS FOR PUBLIC FACING
TECHNOLOGY LAST WEEK WE HAD A
MEETING WHERE WE DISCUSSED THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CONSUMER
PORTAL AND MOBILE APP WHERE.
THE ADVOCATE AND STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY BROUGHT THERE WERE IS
ABLE TO REVIEW THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ALREADY EXIST AND THEN ADD
THEIR OWN AND MAKE COMMENTS ON
THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
NOT WILL BE CONSIDEREDAS WE
DEVELOP THE PROCUREMENT.
AND THEY'RE ALSO BEING INCLUDED
STAKEHOLDERS ARE BEING INCLUDED
IN CAL SIZE FUNCTIONAL DESIGN
SESSIONS PARTICULARLY FOR THE
PUBLIC FACING FUNCTIONALITY AND
THOSE WILL BE SCHEDULED.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
SELECT THEIR INVOLVED IN THE
DESIGN.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE
THE AGENDAS FOR ALL MEETINGS AND
TO DISCUSSION TOPICS FOR THOSE
MEETINGS.
AND IN ADDITION AS YOU HEARD --
DISTURBING TO SAY THAT WE ARE
POSTING ALL RELEVANT DOCUMENTS
TO PUBLIC WEBSITES FOR
STAKEHOLDER REVIEW AND COMMENT
AND QUESTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE
FINDINGS OF THE STATE
APPLICATION HAVE AND HOW THOSE
ARE INFLUENCING DESIGN AND
DEVELOPMENT OF CAL SAUCE.
I THINK YOU HEARD EARLIER THAT
THAT PROJECT IS IN VERY EARLY
STAGES AND SO THERE'S AN
ASSUMPTION AS THE ANALYSIS AND
PLANNING CONTINUES THAT.
THAT PROJECT WILL ENGAGE WITH
CAL SIZE BOTH IN TERMS OF DESIGN
AND ALSO IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
TIGER WOODS BERMAN FINANCE
SOMETHING THAT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
BRENT METZ GRILL A NO COMMENTS
ON THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI THANK YOU TRACI PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES --
I AM PART OF THE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
MEETING REGULARLY BOTH AS OUR
ORGANIZATION A PART OF THE
ALLIANCE TO TRANSFORM CAL FRESH
PARENT VOICES NATIONAL HEALTH
WELL PROGRAM WESTERN CENTER --
AND WE ARE REALLY APPRECIATING
THE MEETINGS AND BREAK THROUGH
THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING LATELY
THINGS WERE DELAYED BECAUSE OF
THE DELAY OF THE SHUT DOWN WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN DIVING INTO SOME MORE IN
DEPTH MEETINGS LATELY.
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS KIND OF
A FIRST -- WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ACKNOWLEDGED AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THIS -- THERE IS
ANOTHER ISSUE WILL HERE IN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
HOPING OF WITH THE PROCESS
LEADING TO OUTCOMES AND HOW THAT
WORKS TOGETHER BUT YOU KNOW
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROCESS AND
TO BE WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
STATE AND COUNTIES ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WELL WE HAVE AS TRACY
MENTIONED WE ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING IN THE SAUCE DECOR
WORKER PROCESS -- AND YEAH I
THINK IT REALLY HAS PICKED UP
STEAM IN THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS --
I THINK WE'RE GETTING MUCH MORE
DEEPLY ENGAGED IT'S A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT.
AND ADD THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DETAIL BUT THAT I
EVERYONE ON OUR SIDE IS LEARNING
ABOUT.
ABOUT THE PROCESS AND WHAT CAN
GAUGE WITHIN HIM WERE HAVING TO
KIND OF FOCUS DOWN ON THE AREAS
THAT REALLY MATTER MOST TO OUR
CLIENTS.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE OPTION TO
COMMENT ON THE HUB BY I ALSO
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT.
THAT IS ALSO REALLY SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT IT
IS IN A REALLY PRELIMINARY STAGE
WE HAVEN'T REALLY DUG INTO THE
DETAILS OF IT YET.
THE PROMISE OF THE HUB COULD
REALLY BE SIGNIFICANT THOUGH AND
THAT IT COULD REALLY HELP US
FINE TUNE AND MAKE BETTER
BENEFIT DETERMINATIONS.
ACCURATE BENEFIT DETERMINATIONS
SO THAT PEOPLE GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED IN A
QUICKER MORE A CORRECT FASHION.
BUT AGAIN WE'RE AT A VERY EARLY
STAGE IT'S A VERY EXCITING TIME
ALL THESE KIND OF CHANGES WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT AND WHAT I I
WOULD SIGNAL I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE.
HAS SENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
IS ALREADY NOTED TO KEEP A SHARP
BY AND FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MACKESY TO BE DA I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S REQUEST FOR
SUPPORT -- FOR THE PROJECT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE THE TRADITION OF
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD WITH SAWS.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING --
MISTER BRAZIER THAT IN THE LIST
OF PROJECTS THAT YOU LISTED THAT
CREATED SOME CONCERNS IN THE
PAST SAUCES NOT BEEN ONE OF THEM
IT'S BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL.
AUTOMATION PROJECTS -- IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY.
TODAY THERE'S ABOUT THIRTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE AS WE SIT HERE IN
THIS HEARING WHO ARE RECEIVING A
VITAL LIFESAVING BENEFIT THAT
THEY LARGELY THIS ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM.
AND SO AS WE MIGRATE FROM THREE
TO ONE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT STAKEHOLDER COLLABORATION
EXISTS IN THE STATE AND THE
COUNTIES HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE THIS TRADITION OF
SUCCESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I DID WANT TO ASK ON PAGE.
THIRTY EIGHT I COULD BE A
DIFFERENT PAGE BUT THE IT'S
TABLE ONE THE RESOURCE REQUEST.
DOES THAT BUDGET PICTURE ALL OF
REFLECT.
THE REQUEST BEING MADE IN THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
YES VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BE HOLDING
THIS ISSUE OPEN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX IT'S ALSO MINE.
ALRIGHT.
STAY RIGHT WHERE YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MCCOURT CWD A SHIP THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
PROPOSAL.
COVERAGE TO PLANO IS A PRACTICE
ENHANCEMENT EFFORT THAT WAS
INITIATED BY THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS. TO MODERNIZE THE WAY
WE DO IN THE WAY WE ENGAGE WITH
CLIENTS IN THE WELFARE TO WORK
PART OF THE CALVERTS PROGRAM.
IT'S BASED ON EXCITING EMERGING
BRAIN SCIENCE BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE.
AND LEVERAGING WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING FROM RESEARCH ABOUT
ADULT ABOUT HOW ADULTS LEARN THE
COW WORKS PROGRAM IS ABOUT TWO
DECADES OLD.
AND THE POINT OF THE TWO POINT
NO EFFORT.
IS TO MOVE THE PROGRAM FROM A
COMPLIANCE ORIENTED --
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS HOW
IT WAS BUILT. TO ONE THAT'S
REALLY BASED ON A MEANINGFUL
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN CASEWORKERS
AND CLIENTS WHERE THEY HELP.
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES WITH BEST
FOR THEMSELVES AND WE CREATE
PLANS WITH THEM.
THAT ARE ACHIEVED THROUGH -- IT
HEARD OF GOAL ATTAINMENT THE
RESEARCH SAYS IT'S A BETTER WAY
TO HELP PEOPLE MOVE ALONG THEIR
JOURNEYS.
ARM IN ARM PUTTING THIS --
INITIATIVE FOURTH WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH THE NATIONAL
EXPERT MATHEMATICA POLICY
RESEARCH.
THAT HAS HELPED US DEVELOP A
NUMBER OF TOOLS FOR WORKERS AND
SUPERVISORS TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THE LEARNING OF CAL WORKS TO
POINT OUT.
THOSE TOOLS ARE LARGELY MANUAL
AND WERE SEEKING.
EXCUSE ME AS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO
INTEGRATE THOSE TOOLS INTO THE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM.
SO THAT IT'S USER FRIENDLY FOR
CLIENTS AND FOR WORKERS THAT THE
DATA THAT WE GET ABOUT CLIENTS
IS INTEGRATED INTO THAT SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE CAN TRACK HOW IT'S
WORKING WE CAN DO RESEARCH ON
HOW IT'S WORKING.
AND WE THINK BY EMBEDDING THOSE
TOOLS INTO THE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEM IT WILL
REALLY HELP WITH AFFECTS WITH
THE CULTURE CHANGE NECESSARY
WHICH IS AT THE ROOT OF SUCCESS
OF THIS PROJECT BECAUSE SHIFTING.
A SYSTEM THAT FOR DECADES HAS
BEEN BASED ON COMPLIANCE TO ONE
THAT'S NOW BASED ON A DIFFERENT
WAY OF ENGAGING IT'S IT'S A
MAJOR FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE.
AND THIS THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
HELP US EFFECTUATE WHAT HAS
BANNED -- OF VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT TO DATE AND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POINT OF VIEW
THE ONLY COMMENT WOULD BE THAT
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF WORK
AHEAD FOR CAL SAWS -- NOT ONLY
THE CONSOLIDATION BUT ALSO OTHER
POLICY CHANGES THAT ARE THERE
AND SO THIS WOULD THERE HAVE TO
BE CLOSE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE COUNTIES
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR IN TERMS OF
PRIORITIZING.
THIS WEEK AUTOMATION ABSOLUTELY
MORE INTIMATELY WERE INTIMATELY
ENGAGED IN THOSE PRIORITIZATION
DISCUSSIONS THAT.
AS WE MOVE TOWARD CAL SAUCE SO.
WE COMPLETELY -- UNDERSTAND AND
AND AGREE WITH THAT -- CABBIE
OUT [inaudible]
WONDERFUL.
LET'S OPEN IT UP I'M SORRY --
PARTNER FINANCE.
FINANCE TYLER WOULD SIDE JUST
ECHO.
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID THAT
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
PROPOSALS SUCH AS THESE THE
REQUIREMENTS AND CHANGES IN SIZE --
THERE SHOULD BE SOME
CONSIDERATION GIVEN THE CAPACITY
OF THE CONSORTIUM MAKE THESE
CHANGES IN ANY GIVEN FISCAL YEAR.
THANK YOU AND BRIAN METZGER LEO
NO COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU A PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN MY
CAROL WITH WESTERN CENTER ALONG
POVERTY WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
FROM WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL OF POWERS TWO
POINT NO I PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF THIS.
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE MERITS OF
THAT -- AND WE'RE WE'RE ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COUNTIES IN THE DEPARTMENT
TO IN FACT CREATE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD.
BRING BACK RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
FURTHER POLICY CHANGES THAT
WOULD EMBRACE COWART'S TWO POINT
OH SO WE WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL URGE YOU.
TO CONSIDER WHEN THE TIME COMES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS AUTOMATION PIECE DOES FEEL
LIKE A NATURAL PART OF THE CAL
WORKS.
OUT COMES IN ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW CALOR -- I WOULD ASK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE
US YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW.
THE TOOLS RELATE TO CAL OR IN
YOUR MIND [inaudible]
THE TICKET.
TIGER WOODS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
I'M THE EXPERT THAT YOU'D WANT
TO HEAR FROM REGARDING THE
INTERFACE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
THINGS CAL OR AND CAL WORKS TWO
POINT NOW -- MANIC BUT HEY
MISTER MARKER CAM ALL RIGHT
MISTER MECCA.
THEY'RE THEY'RE INTIMATELY
RELATED AND SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MATERIALS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS PUT TOGETHER ON THE MEASURES
THAT WILL BE PART OF THE CAL OR
THE CAL WORKS OUT COMES AN
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW SYSTEM.
THERE ARE MEASURES THAT -- LIKE
ENGAGEMENT THEIR MEASURES FOR
PARTIAL PARTICIPATION THEIR
MEASURES FOR THE ACCESS TO
SUPPORT OF SERVICES THERE
MEASURES RELATED.
TO OUR PEOPLE DOING ONCE THEY
GET EMPLOYED -- THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT PART OF THEY WERE
BUILT INTO THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
THE CALYX TO PLANO APPROACH TO
CASE MANAGEMENT IS ALL ABOUT
ENGAGEMENT.
BUILDING ON PARTIAL
PARTICIPATION BUILDING ON GOAL
ATTAINMENT SO THAT -- THAT A
CLIENT JOURNEY -- TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY IS ONE THAT'S BUILT
ON ATTAINING GOALS ITS EGGS IT'S
EXACTLY HOW.
EXACTLY IT'S IT IS LARGELY
REFLECTED AND SUPPORTED IN THE
TYPES OF MEASURES THAT ARE PART
OF CALOR AND THE CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROCESS.
THAT IS PART OF THE CALORIMETER
SO WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE --
THEY'RE THEY'RE COMPLETELY
SYNERGISTIC AND AND NEITHER WILL
BE AS SUCCESSFUL BY ITSELF.
THEN THEY WILL BE TOGETHER.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER. SEVEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FRANK MECCA AGAIN
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS -- COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS BY STATUTE WHEN
THERE IS A A A NATURAL DISASTER
HAVE TWO MAJOR RESPONSIBILITIES
ONE IS A MATCH SHELTERING OF
DISPLACED PEOPLE AND ONE IS THE
ISSUANCE OF EMERGENCY BENEFITS.
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN SURVIVE --
WHILE OTHER ADJUSTING TO THEIR
THEIR LIFE POST TRAGEDY -- ONE
OF THOSE PROGRAMS IS THE
DISASTER CALPERS PROGRAM WHICH
WE ADMINISTER AND IT'S LARGELY A
MANUALLY ADMINISTERED PROGRAM.
AND WITH THE REGRETTABLE BUT IT
WOULD SEEM TO NEVER DOUBLE
INCREASING FREQUENCY OF MASS
DISASTERS.
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT FOR
WORKERS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR
CLIENTS THE MANUAL PROCESS OF
APPLYING AND TRACKING AND
ISSUING BENEFITS FOR DISASTER
CAL BRUSH BENEFITS?
DIVERTS ATTENTION AWAY FROM
HELPING PEOPLE -- GET ACCLIMATED --
TO AN INTERIM EXISTENCE AND
SURVIVE -- AS THEY AS THEY DEAL
WITH THE WITH THE HORRORS OF
THEIR TRAGEDIES WE'VE ALSO FOUND
THAT AS NEIGHBORING COUNTIES
MOVING TO ASSIST PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISPLACED FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE
THE BUYERS AND BUTTE COUNTY
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES WERE
RECEIVING CLIENTS WHO ARE MOVING
BECAUSE THERE'S NO PLACE TO LIVE --
THE ABILITY TO TRACK CENTRALLY
IN AN AUTOMATED WAY THE THAT THE
CLIENTS ENGAGEMENT WITH THIS
AFTER BENEFITS WOULD HELP THE
RECEIVING COUNTIES UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE FAMILY.
AND BE ABLE TO HELP RELOCATE --
AND ASSIST THEM IN SO THIS IS
THE NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND AT ONE TIME ASK --
IT'S ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONCE WE ADD THE FEDERAL FUNDS --
THAT WE BELIEVE IS A REALLY
PRUDENT AND NECESSARY COMPONENT
TO THE STATE'S A STRATEGY FOR
DEALING WITH NATURAL DISASTERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
FEATURING GO WITH DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WE CONCUR
COMPLETELY WITH THE PROBLEM THAT
MISTER MAC AT DESCRIBE THIS IS
AN INTENSELY MANUAL WORK AROUND
IT'S UNPREDICTABLE WHEN IT
HAPPENS -- IT'S NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- SO YOU KNOW
MY ABILITY TO COMMENT TOO FAR IS
IS LIMITED -- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING AS WELL THIS IS A
ONE ONE TIME I REQUEST FOR
FUNDING -- DEBT THAT WOULD -- IN
A IN A TIME OF EMERGENCY GIVE
PEOPLE CLEARANCE STANDARD
UNDERSTANDING OF OF WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO AND HOW TO GO ABOUT
DOING IT.
AN INCREASE THE ABILITY TO DO
THE REPORTING THAT'S REQUIRED TO
THE FADS -- AS YOU KNOW AT THE
SAME COMMENTS MADE ON THE PRIOR
ITEM SAWS HAS A BIG LIST -- AND
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE THAT SWIRLY
A PRIORITIZATION WITHIN THE LIST.
THANK YOU YOU WOULD TEND TO
AGREE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
TIGER WOODS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGAIN SIMILAR COMMENTS
TO THE PROPOSAL BEFORE THIS THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER SAYS
SAYS A PROPOSAL -- TO GIVE DUE
CONSIDERATION THE CAPACITY TO
BUILD THESE AUTOMATION CHANGES
IN THE SAUCE AND BUDGET YEAR.
THE MANAGER PACKAGE TO SAY ON
THAT POINT.
UNDERSCORE THAT THE CAPACITY OF
THE CONSORTIA IS A REALLY
RELEVANT.
FACTOR WE ARE THE CONSORTIA
[inaudible]
OUR COUNTY -- STAFFING MANAGERS
AND SO WE HAVE AS VESTED.
EQUALLY AS VESTED IN A IN A
RATIONAL ACHIEVABLE
PRIORITIZATION BECAUSE BECAUSE
THAT IS COUNTY STAFF THAT
ACTUALLY MAKE UP THE CONSORTIUM
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER THOMAS WE
DIDN'T MEAN TO IMPLY OTHERWISE.
FOR THE RECORD.
YOU.
LA AND PRIVATE SCALIA NO
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE THIS
ISSUE OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LNGUAGE RELATED TO QUALITY
APPLICANT CLIENT EXPERIENCE.
YES HI TRACY PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES --
HERE TO PRESENT ON SORT OF A
FOLLOW UP A LOT OF A LOT OF
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN COMING UP
TODAY WITHIN THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUP THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
WITH THE CAL SAWS DEVELOPMENT.
ON THIS HAS BEEN A GOOD PROCESS
IT'S BEEN OPENING UP AGAIN WE
REALLY APPRECIATE SORT OF THIS
HISTORIC NATURE AND ALSO YOU
KNOW SOMEOF THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE GOVERNANCE OF THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S A COUNTY SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO ADMINISTERED BY THE
CONSORTIUM WHICH ARE THE
COUNTIES BUT OUR CALLUSES WITH
OVERSIGHT FROM THE STATE SO IN
BEING STAKEHOLDERS TRYING TO
ENGAGE WITH THOSE VARIOUS.
OTHER SERVE GOVERNMENT
STAKEHOLDERS WHAT WE LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT PROCESS
LEADS TO THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
REALLY WANT FOR OUR CLIENTS
WHICH IS.
AN EASIER EXPERIENCE A DIGNIFIED
EXPERIENCE AWAY TO GET ENROLLED
WITH SUCCESS TO NOT DROP OFF IT
POINTS OF OF PAIN IN THE
TRANSITION WHICH FOR CAL FOR US
CAN OFTEN BE THE VERIFICATION.
INTERVIEWS TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SYSTEM REALLY GUIDES
PEOPLE FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE
END BECAUSE WE KNOW AN
APPLICATION IS NOT ACTUALLY AN
ENROLLMENT NECESSARILY YOU HAVE
TO HAVE.
YOU'RE REALLY STARTING THE
BEGINNING THE AWARENESS OF THE
PROGRAM YOU NEED GOOD WORD OF
MOUTH YOU NEED A COMMUNITY THAT
REALLY TRUST THAT THE SYSTEM
WORKS TO ENROLL -- THEN THERE'S
THE APPLICATION GETTING VERIFIED
GETTING ROLLED AND THEN STAYING
ENROLLED PEOPLE HAVE TO
RECERTIFY WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
DROP OFF.
AND SO AS WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
WHAT WE'RE HOPING IS THAT WE CAN
THEN HAVE SOME I'M SORT OF
SIMILAR TO THE CAL OR PROCESS
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT THROUGH THAT PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE WEGET THOSE
OUTCOMES?
AND SO ALL THAT WERE REQUESTING
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BEEN CONSULTING THE
COUNTY IS -- THE ADMINISTRATION
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE GET THIS
LANGUAGE RIGHT -- AND SO THERE
ARE YOU KNOW SOME CHANGES TO THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THIS AGENDA
THAT WERE WORKING ON BOTH TO
CLARIFY WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REPORTING ON THE PROGRESS AND
THE OUTCOMES WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT FORMAL REPORT.
WE'RE HAPPY WITH THAT BEING AN
UPDATE TO THE LEGISLATURE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
ENGAGED IN INVOLVED -- AND
MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW WITHIN
TECHNOLOGY TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT
WITH AN EXISTING TECHNOLOGY OR
MINIMIZING THE BURDENS OF THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS AND THAT THAT
IS SORT OF THE GUIDING STAR.
OF THESE WORK GROUPS BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S THIRTY FOUR
DIFFERENT WORK GROUPS NOW WE
CAN'T ALL BE IN ALL PLACES AT
THAT TIME AND SO WHAT WE'RE
HOPING THROUGH THIS IS THAT.
AS CHANGES ARE MADE AS I. T.
DECISIONS ARE MADE THAT WERE
ASKING IS THIS DECISION ACTUALLY
REDUCING THE BURDEN FOR THE
CLIENT IT IS BEING DONE IN FOR
MY BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE.
UNDERSTANDING MANY PEOPLE COMING
TO THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EXPERIENCING POVERTY TRAUMA A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES AND SO THE
COSTS SERVE COGNITIVE LOAD
BEHAVIORAL ATTENTION THE ABILITY
TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX SYSTEMS CAN
BE MUCH HARDER FOR THESE CLIENTS.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROCESS LEADS TO THE
OUTCOMES -- WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT CAN BE CHALLENGE
CHALLENGING TO PUT INTO
STATUTORY LANGUAGE AND SO WE'RE
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
HAVE PROCESS AND OUTCOMES THAT
LEAD TO WHAT WE ALL WANT AT THE
END OF THIS MULTI YEAR PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
AGAIN PETER BANKER FROM FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES WE
DON'T HAVE OBJECTIONS TO
CODIFYING OF THIS I THINK WE'D
HAVE TO MINOR COMMENTS THAT AS
SHE ALLUDED TO LIKE A GUIDING
STAR -- IT'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN
AS A MANDATE THAT THE SYSTEM
SHALL WE THINK MAYBE EXPRESSING
IT AS A GOAL WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND THERE'S A A REQUIREMENT IN
AS THE DRAFT ON PAGE FORTY FIVE
ABOUT AT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TWICE A YEAR.
AS WE TALKED ABOUT A LOT TODAY --
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE AWAY FROM
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LONG FORMAL
REVIEW PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT.
AND SIMPLY MAINTAINING AND
MAKING AVAILABLE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION DOCUMENTATION AND
NOTES ON OUR PUBLIC FACING
WEBSITES SO THAT WERE FULLY
TRANSPARENT NOT JUST TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ANYBODY THAT
MAYBE COULDN'T ATTEND A MEETING
OR SO FORTH SO.
WITH THOSE TWO MINOR SUGGESTIONS
AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS AT
ALL WE WERE SUPPORTIVE.
THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE ALL
HERE TO SERVE CLIENTS AND IF IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR CLIENTS THERE'S
NO POINT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FIND.
TIGER WOODS HER TO FINANCE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
HELLO PRIME IT'S CURLY -- NO
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE SUPPORT THIS.
REQUEST FOR SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT I TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
ABOUT THE NEED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO STAY INFORMED I
THINK THIS LANGUAGE WILL
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
A RITE.
OF ALTHOUGH I RECOGNIZE THAT --
HAVING THE OF RETURNING.
A HAVING THE INFORMATION ON ON
THE WEBSITE AND MAKING A PUBLIC
IS A GOOD THING I I WOULD ASK
THAT IT BE SHARED WITH THE WITH
THE STAFF WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING -- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOUR YOUR FEEDBACK IS THAT YOU
LIKE THE PROPOSAL.
I I WOULD ASK THAT THE ALLIANCE
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
SPECIFIC EDITS TO THE LANGUAGE --
AND I'D LIKE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THE CLOSE
VERSION TWO FINAL VERSION OF
SUBMITTED.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE -- BY NEXT
WEEK.
WE CAN OKAY.
OKAY AND WITH THAT WILL LEAVE
THIS ISSUE OPEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
.
RIGHT ISSUE.
NINE ON STATE WHAT FINGERPRINT
IMAGING SYSTEM.
AGAIN PETER REGULAR THAT
APARTMENT ON THIS ONE THIS IS
BASICALLY CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO
ACTIONS -- DONE IN IN PRIOR
BUDGET CYCLES WE'VE ENDED THE
USE OF THE STATEWIDE FINGERPRINT
IMAGING SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE A
COUPLE PLACES IN THE CODE THAT
WERE MESSED WHERE WE HAD
REFERENCES TO IT THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO REPLACE -- AND SO
THAT'S REALLY ALL THIS LANGUAGE
DOES IT'S CLEAN UP FOR THAT --
I'D BE REMISS NOT TO MENTION
THAT -- THE DECOMMISSIONING AS
WELL SO JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
FOR THE RECORD BUT THE ITEM
BEFORE YOU IS THE TRAILER BILL
AND IT'S SIMPLY CODE CLEAN UP.
WHERE WE MISSED A FEW REFERENCES
TO THE OLD SYSTEM?
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
TIGER WOODS PARMA FINANCE NO
COMMENT.
BRENT METZ GRILL A WE'VE
REVIEWED THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND AGREE IT'S LARGELY
TECHNICAL AND HAVE NO CONCERNS.
THANK YOU PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WILL LEAVE THIS ISSUE OPENED.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
TEN THE UPDATE [inaudible]
PUBLICATION.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
BEING NUMBER.
TEN THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
HAVE LOTS OF THINGS LOTS OF
ISSUES TO DEAL WITH.
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'VE
TAKEN A LOT OF YOUR TIME AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR PATIENCE IN
THIS REGARD WELL YOU'RE
CERTAINLY WELCOME -- AND
COMPLIMENTS TO FOR MOVING THE
AGENDA LONG PRETTY PRETTY
EFFICIENTLY.
OF MY NAME IS -- REBEKAH
STILLING I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF WITH THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AND MY ROLE -- WITH
OSIIS THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA AUTOMATED
RESPONSE AN ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM.
TO MY RIGHT IS MY COLLEAGUE
KEVIN GAINS -- SOCIAL SERVICES
AND OSI -- UNDER THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS -- IMPORTANT
SYSTEM FOR CHILD WELFARE WORKERS
AND AND FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
OF THIS STUFF THE SUMMARY AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IS ACCURATE AND
WILL WELL WRITTEN -- I'LL ADD A
FEW MORE THINGS TO IT OVER THIS
PAST YEAR IN ADDITION TO WORKING
ON ONE THING AT A TIME WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IMPROVING OUR
CAPABILITIES AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ENTIRETY OF
THE SYSTEM -- WHICH INCLUDED --
AN EFFORT TO DOCUMENT WHAT WE
CALL THE BLUEPRINT OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THAT'S GOING TO
BE HELPFUL IN FUTURE YEARS
BECAUSE IT WILL.
GIVE US A CHANCE TO FOCUS ON THE
SPECIFICS OF THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS -- AND HELP US WITH OUR
FOCUS ON THE USER CENTERED
DESIGN AND USER RESEARCH
ACTIVITIES.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THIS PAST
YEAR WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS TO ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS EVENTUALLY.
I THINK WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THIS PROJECT WE WERE A LITTLE
NAIVE ABOUT HOW TO DO -- AGILE
PROJECTS AND A LITTLE BIT NAIVE
ON THE APPROACH TO BUILDING THIS
SYSTEM -- USING CUSTOM
DEVELOPMENT APPROACH AND THAT
WAS WHAT PRECIPITATED THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM A SEE WHY I
HAVE TO DO ONE THING AT A TIME
IN OTHER WORDS GET BETTER AT
COMPLETING SOMETHING ALL THE WAY
THROUGH DON'T START TOO MANY
THINGS AT ONCE AND SO WE'VE
TAKEN THAT.
ADVICE TO HEART AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT APPROACH INTO THE
NEXT YEAR -- AND AND ALLOW US --
TO SHOW AND DELIVER THE THING
THE VALUE -- ESPECIALLY THE
VALUE TO THE CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS AS WELL AS THE FAMILIES.
SO I'LL I'LL STOP AT THAT
OBSERVATION AND AND FIGHT
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IF YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
KEVIN GAINES SOCIAL SERVICES --
JUST AS WELL ABOVE BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND -- THE THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE --
DEPLOYED TALK COUNTY SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT STARTED AS
A PROJECT IN ABOUT NINETEEN
NINETY TWO AND REPRESENTS -- THE
STATE OF THE ART FOR NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND SO WHILE THERE
IS A DIRE NEED -- TO TO TO
REPLACE AND AND CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE ON WORKERS ABILITY TO
ADD TO IT TO ACCESS INFORMATION
AND DISPENSE INFORMATION AND
TRADE INFORMATION TO TO MAKE
SURE THEY EVERYONE IS
COLLABORATING TOWARD THE RIGHT
OUTCOMES FOR KIDS AND FAMILIES --
THE THAT THAT HAS BEEN SLOW
GOING AND WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN -- LONG
LONG COMING.
AND AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
IT'S WE AGREE WITH THE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO TO STEP BACK.
FIGURE OUT -- AS A PUBLIC SECTOR
ENTITY HOW TO HOW TO BUILD
SOFTWARE IN THE WAYS THAT --
THAT PRIVATE INDUSTRY DOES BUT
IN A IN A WAY THAT'S TRANSPARENT
AS OPPOSED TO THE WAY PRIVATE
INDUSTRY IS NOT.
IN AND AND SO -- THAT'S WE KNEW
IN THE BEGINNING WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS AS A AS A AS A POSSIBLE
TRANSITION -- OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IT
WAS GONNA TAKES A MAJOR --
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES AND AND
AND NEW PARADIGMS AND SO WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
I GUESS MY MY MY MESSAGES WHILE
WE WE DON'T WANT TO THROW THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BATHWATER --
YOU KNOW MISTAKES IN EXECUTION
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT WERE THAT
WERE STANDING ON A BAD IDEA WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO TO REFINE.
OUR PROCESSES AND AND REFINED.
THE THE AND AND REDEFINE THE
TYPES OF PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING
THIS WORK AND KEEP UP WITH WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND THE STAFF WAS SO --
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO RELY ON EXPERTS -- THE WHO
WERE COMING FROM PRIVATE
INDUSTRY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
CONSULTING WITH -- WITH HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND
WITH OUR NEW ADVISER OF MIKE
WILKENING FOR FOR DIGITAL
INNOVATION WE WANT.
TO CONTINUE -- TO TO TO TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR OUR PROCESS
IS TO TO GET BETTER AT
DELIVERING SOFTWARE WHETHER IT'S
VIA OTHER AND AND PLATFORM OR
CUSTOM BUILT -- SO WE IT ALL
IT'S IT'S BABY STEPS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADD TO IT TO GROW
MATURE SO WE WOULD LIKE -- TO TO
TO HAVE ROOM TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
WHICH ISN'T REGISTERED OWNER
FINANCE SEVEN NO COMMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
BRENT METZ GALLIO.
I WERE ENCOURAGED BY THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THE PROJECT HAS
UNDERTAKEN TO TRY -- TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
ARISEN WITH THE PROJECT OVER THE
PAST YEAR OR SO BUT WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE PROJECT IS STILL
CONTINUING TO OPERATE WITH AN
OUTDATED -- COSTS GO OPEN
SCHEDULE BASELINE -- THEY'RE
OPERATING UNDER A PRIOR SB ARE
THAT WAS APPROVED I BELIEVE IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN SO -- IN THE
PROJECT IS WORKING ON A NEW S.
P. R. THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED
HOPEFULLY IN SUMMER -- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO VALUE WAITING
THE S. P. R. IN PROVIDING OUR
COMMENTS ON THAT WE WOULDN'T
KNOW IT AS THE AGENDA NOTES THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY
SIX MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS FOR
THIS PROJECT THIRTEEN MILLION OF
WHICH IS GENERAL FUND -- IN THE
ABSENCE OF A NEW S. P. R. THAT
RE BASS LINES THE PROJECT THAT
FUNDING AMOUNT IS LARGELY PLACE
HOLDER -- AND THERE'S YOU KNOW
THIS IS SOMEWHAT CONSISTENT WITH
PRIOR FUNDING AMOUNTS FOR THIS
PROJECT IN THAT -- THE PROJECT
IS NOT SPENT OPTED THE
APPROPRIATED AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN AND
PRIOR FISCAL YEARS SO AGAIN WE
WE LOOK FOR TO EVALUATING THIS
PR BUT WANTED TO PROVIDE THOSE
NOTES ABOUT THE NINETEEN TWENTY
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
MEETING.
CAN YOU TELL US HOW THE COST AND
TIME LINES FOR SEATS CWS CARES
HAVE SHIFTED.
YES WELL HOW COME THE THE THE
TIME LINES HAVE SHIFTED IN --
AND WE AS SOME FRIEND MENTIONED
A MINUTE AGO WE'RE WORKING ON A
NEW SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT --
AND IN WORKING ON THIS THE
BLUEPRINT THAT I REFERENCED AND
THE MODIFICATIONS TO OUR
DEVELOPMENT APPROACH.
WE INTEND TO BUILD OUT A NEW --
A PROJECTION ON SCHEDULING COST
AND THE THE EXPECTATION -- IN
THAT CONTEXT WOULD BE THAT IT'LL
IT'LL STILL -- TAKE US SOME
ADDITIONAL NUMBERS OF YEARS AND
I WOULD GUESS ABOUT FOUR AT THIS
POINT FOUR MORE YEARS TO FINISH
THIS UP THAT'S A GAS.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND IT'S IT'S
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT THE
PROJECT -- USING THIS APPROACH
AGILE SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT THAT
OLOGY WILL -- CONTINUE ON INTO
THE FUTURE AS THE SYSTEM LIVES
SO IT WILL -- IT'LL REQUIRE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR MAINTAINING
AND OPERATING IT WITH THE
AMBITION THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE IT AND MODIFY IT AS
IT DOES.
SO -- WANT WHEN I TYPICALLY
THINK OF A PROJECT TIMELINE I
THINK OF WHEN YOU GET TO FULL
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THEY'LL BE A TIME THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO TURN OFF THE CMS
SYSTEM THE LEGACY SYSTEM.
AND A TIME WHEN WHEN ALL --
CHILD WELFARE WORKERS ARE
UTILIZING THE NEW SYSTEM BUT
THEN THEY'LL BE SUBSEQUENT
PERIODS OF YOU KNOW THEY'LL
THEY'LL BE ONGOING ENHANCEMENTS
MADE TO THE SYSTEM AFTER THAT I
THINK. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
STATE LEGACY SYSTEMS IS THAT --
WE WE WORK REALLY HARD WE GET
THE PROJECT DONE FOR BETTER OR
WORSE WITH THE WITH A LARGE --
COMPLEMENT OF UNMET NEEDS AND
THEN THE SYSTEMS ARE NOT
INVESTED IN ANYMORE SO THAT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM AS
KEVIN INDICATED THAT WAS
DEPLOYED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT VERY
LITTLE IN TERMS OF MODERNIZING
THE TECHNOLOGY VIRTUALLY NOTHING
IS TAKING PLACE IN THAT SYSTEM
ALL THE TIME.
LOTS OF POLICY REQUIREMENTS OF
WITHIN BECAUSE YOU KNOW
REQUIREMENTS -- HAVE COME ABOUT
BUT NOT ANY MODERNIZATION SO.
THIS SYSTEM -- THE PART OF THE
DEMONSTRATION PRODUCT UP PROP
ASPECT OF THIS SYSTEM IS.
LET'S GET GOOD AT UNDERSTANDING
ARCHITECTURE IN CREATING A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS US TO ENHANCE
IN OVERTIME AND THEN LET'S KEEP.
AN ORGANIZATION IN PLACE ONGOING
THAT WILL MAINTAIN AND OPERATE
THAT SYSTEM FOR YEARS TO COME SO
THEY'LL NEVER AGAIN GET OUTDATED --
AND THE WILL NEVER AGAIN HAVE TO
GIVE GIVE UP.
BUT THAT.
THAT'S A SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
MINDSET AND DIFFERENT SKILL SET
I THINK THEM WHAT WE ORIGINALLY
UNDERSTOOD FULL ANDTHAT'S WHY
WE'RE SPENDING THIS ADDITIONAL
TIME INVESTING IN THAT -- THE S.
P. R. THAT WE FINISH UP -- AND
AND DELIVER THIS MID SUMMER WILL
ALSO BE -- ACCOMPANIED BY A
FEDERAL APPROVAL.
PLANNING DOCUMENT AS WELL AND WE
WILL PROJECT THAT THE COST TO
GET TO THE POINT OF COMPLETING
FOR REPLACEMENT OF THE CMS
SYSTEM -- AND IT'LL BE A
PLACEHOLDER AMOUNTS FOR
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT BUT BUT WE'LL
TRY TO GIVE SOME RELATIVE ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE OF TIME AND MONEY
AND THAT S. P. R..
WONDERFUL IT ARE ARE YOU WHAT
KIND OF FEEDBACK ARE YOU GETTING
FROM COUNTY.
STAFF AND MANAGERS.
OF THE ENTIRE PROJECT IN THE THE
FUNCTIONALITY THUS FAR YEAH WE
WE HAVE.
THE BENEFIT OF OF COUNTY --
ENGAGEMENT VERY ACTIVELY IN THIS
PROJECT THEY THERE ARE COUNTY --
CONSULTANTS THAT ARE PART OF THE
PROJECT TEAM THEIR EMBEDDED WITH
US AND WORK WITH US EVERYDAY ON
DEVELOPMENT OF REQUIREMENTS
DEVELOPMENT OF CLARITY AROUND --
BUSINESS PROCESSES BUSINESS
PRACTICES WE ALSO HAVE A
COMPLEMENT COUNTIES THAT -- ARE
WHAT WE REFER TO AS THE CORE
COUNTY GROUP THEY'RE THEY'RE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE VOLUNTEERED
TO BE.
OUR FEEDBACK LOOP ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF VARIOUS
ASPECTS AND YOU CAN SEE IN THE
REPORT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A FEW
THINGS AND THOSE -- THOSE
COUNTIES ARE ARE UBER -- TESTERS
UBER USERS AND THEY GIVE US THAT
FEEDBACK.
ON HOW TO IMPROVE OUR ENHANCE
THINGS SO -- AND THEN PART OF
OUR EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM OF
THE PROJECT INCLUDES THE
DELEGATION OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE NAME IS WENDY CHRISTIAN --
AND SHE COMES FROM CWD A HA AND
AND PARTICIPATES ON OUR OUR
TWICE WEEKLY LEADERSHIP TEAM
MEETING SHE LEADS THE COUNTY
STAFF ON THE PROJECT SO.
KEVIN MYSELF AND WENDY REPRESENT
THE THREE GOVERNANCE -- POINTS
OF THE PROJECT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT ALL OF THOSE VOICES ARE
HEARD.
OUR INITIAL FEEDBACK FROM
COUNTIES -- HAS BEEN --
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROCESS OF
INCLUDING THEM THEY'VE BEEN VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE OF THE FOCUS
OF USING USER RESEARCH USER
CENTERED DESIGN -- THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT -- ASPECT OF CREATING
ON THE NEW SYSTEM BECAUSE YOU
NEED TO TO REALLY ACTUALLY SEE
WHAT THEY DO AND ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE IN A IN A VISIONING
PUT IT THAT WAY SESSION OF HOW
TO GET THINGS DONE -- BETTER SO
FOR EXAMPLE AGAIN JUST GIVE YOU
A QUICK EXAMPLE NOT TAKE UP TOO
MUCH MORE OF YOUR TIME BUT ONE
WHEN WE SAT DOWN WITH PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN THE PROGRAM AREA ON THE
SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE AND THE
COUNTY USERS.
AND WE SAID HOW DO WE IMPROVE
THIS PROCESS AND RESOURCE FAMILY
APPLICATION IS AN EGG IS THE
EXAMPLE I'M THINKING OF
EVERYBODY WAS SAYING IT TAKES
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN DAYS NOW ON
AVERAGE FOR AN APPLICATION TO GO
THROUGH.
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING CLOSER TO
WHAT IS IT. ONE ONE SIXTY OR
NINETY NINETY SORRY HOW NEW IS A
LOT SHORTER IT SHOULD BE CLOSER
TO NINETY AND SO -- THE PROCESS
WE GO THROUGH IS TO SAY OKAY
LET'S MAP OUT HOW IT IS AND THEN
WE LOOK TOGETHER AND THE
COUNTIES BECOME IMPORTANT
FEEDBACK LOOP HERE. TO SAY COULD
WE DO ATTRACT THIS PROCESS COULD
WE LEAPFROG OVER THIS THIS --
DEPENDENCY HERE AND PICK IT UP
LATER SO THERE'S A LOT OF
BUSINESS PROCESS REVIEW AN
ADDITION TO JUST HOW THE SYSTEM
WILL ACTUALLY FUNCTION.
AND WE CAN'T DO THAT BUSINESS
PROCESS REVIEW WITHOUT COUNTY
ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE WOULD
PROBABLY MESS UP -- WE WOULD
MAKE A AN ASSUMPTION THAT THEY
DON'T NEED TO MEET WITH CLIENTS
SECOND YOU KNOWING SAVE TIME
DON'T MEET WITH THE CLIENTS --
THAT WOULD BE WRONG ALRIGHT SO --
COUNTY PARTICIPATION IN THAT AS
WELL AS SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION IS IMPORTANT.
THAT ACTIVE PARTICIPATION.
IS TAKES A LOT MORE TIME THAN
PEOPLE GOING INTO A ROOM AND
WRITING REQUIREMENTS FOR SYSTEM
AND THROWING IT OVER THE WALL --
IT JUSTDOES AND BUT IT IT'LL
END UP WITH A BETTER RESULT.
AND THE THE GETTING USED TO
LISTENING TO EACH OTHER AND
CARING ABOUT EACH OTHER'S A BIG
PART OF OF WHAT ULTIMATELY THIS
PROJECT IS DESIGNED TO DO.
ANDI THINK THE END RESULT IS
GOING TO BE SO MUCH BETTER I
THINK SO -- WONDERFUL -- YES
MOST FRAZIER.
I SINCE THE YOUR FRUSTRATION ON
FROM NINETY TWO TO NINETY AND
THEN NINETY EIGHT NOW I'VE.
I GET IT -- I THINK THAT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE AND WE LOOK AT
FUTURE GOALS TO GO FOR THAT WE
HAVE AN INDEXING.
ON A BUDGET INCREASE EVERY YEAR
TO BE ABLE.
TO ACCOMMODATE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF PUTTING FORTH I
THINK IT ACTUALLY WOULD BE A
MONEY SAVER -- RATHER THAN
REVAMPING THE WHOLE PROGRAM OR
SIT SITUATION REPORT.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE TO BE.
MAYBE -- OF COLLABORATION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AND
AND LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT WOULD BE.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PROCESS IS AN ONGOING
UPGRADE YES GOING FORWARD I
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
BUSINESS THE PRIVATE SECTOR DOES
IT -- I DON'T SEE WHY WE SHOULD
BE.
DOING THE SAME THING I APOLOGIZE
FOR TWENTY YEARS OF OF OF
WAITING.
AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
AGENCIES WILLINGNESS.
TO ADVANCE TO SERVICE THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT.
HI I SEE THAT ONGOING MESSAGE
GOING FORWARD HOW WE CAN BETTER
SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT NIGHT I CAN'T THANK
YOU ENOUGH FOR THAT IT'S NO.
USE FACE OF GOVERNMENT WELL AS
ACTUALLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT --
NEED YOUR HELP AND THE BETTER
THAT WE CAN SERVE YOU CONSERVE
THEM ACTUALLY HELPS US ALSO IN
OUR OR WAY OF REPRESENTING SO --
LOOKING FOR DOOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO AND HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SOMETHING
THEM.
AS A AN ONGOING SUPPORT LOVELY
THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER WAS
VERY WELL PUT.
MISTER RAMOS NIGHT JOIN IN IN
THAT SENTIMENT AND DID NOT ONLY
WITH THE TWO OF YOU HERE OR HERE
ALL OF YOU WHO WERE HERE BEFORE
US.
BUT EVERYBODY ELSE WAS PRESENTED
ON THE VARIOUS ISSUES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT JUST THE THE
BUDGET ASPECT OF IT.
THERE'S A HUMAN ASPECT AND YOU
ALL ARE DOING [inaudible]
GREAT JOB.
OF TAKING CARE OF THAT AND
KEEPING THAT AT THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE THAT WE
DISCUSS.
THE MAY ONLY BE TALKING DOLLARS
HERE BUT WHICH YOU DO IN YOUR
DEPARTMENTS HAS TO DO WITH THE
PEOPLE THINKING SO I TO JOIN
MISTER FRAZIER AND THANKING YOU.
FOR VERY GOOD WELL THIS IS BEEN
AN OVERSIGHT ISSUE OF FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING
IT.
WE'VE ALREADY DEALT WITH ISSUE
ELEVEN SO.
ISSUE NUMBER
.
TWELVE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MY MIDDLE
MIDDLE AND I AM THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE.
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
STATE HEARINGS DIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES -- THE STAFF HAS DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB IN LAYING OUT OF
OF THE REQUEST -- I WILL VERY
VERY BRIEFLY HE JUST SUMMARIZE
IT IN JUST A FEW SENTENCES --
WERE ASKING -- FOR THREE UP
POSITIONS TO CONTINUE THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION NOW
THAT WE SUCCESSFULLY HAVE --
ROLLED OUT IN HAVE GONE LIVE --
WITH THE NEW APPEALS CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWS OUR DIVISION TO JOIN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ANY IN
THE BACK ON IT OF PERMISSION YOU
KNOW THAT WE WERE OPERATING
UNDER A VERY DECENTRALIZED AND
FRAGMENTED.
PROCESS SINCE -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN AND I THINK THIS
IS A PROJECT THAT WE CAN POINT.
TO OF THAT IT WAS IS A
SUCCESSFUL ONE IN IN THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DELIVER IT.
ON TIME -- WITHIN SCOPE A AN
WITHIN BUDGET A AND NOW WE'RE IN
A CRITICAL PHASE AS WE JUST.
A NOTICE IN THE PRIOR PROJECT OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION.
I AM GOING FORTH -- WITH THE
PRODUCT THAT IS HIGHLY
CONFIGURABLE MEANING THAT WE
HAVE A A A PROCESS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO MAKE CHANGES TO IT.
AS CHANGES OCCUR DUE TO BUY
THEIR STATUTORY CHANGES IN ANY
OF THE PROGRAMS.
OR NEW PROGRAMS MAY BE ON THE
HORIZON -- OR ANYTHING THAT IS
COURT COURT ORDERED ON A THAT WE
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH -- WE NOW
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS US.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
AND NOT WAIT YEARS -- FOR TO BE
WILL IMPLEMENT AND HAVE A
PROCESS.
WHERE WE CAN ULTIMATELY REACH
THE AW COME OF THAT OUR ENTIRE
PROCESSES IN EVERYBODY ENGAGE
WITH IT?
IS IS WORKING TOWARDS AND THAT
IS THE BUT TIMELY LEGALLY
CORRECT DECISION.
IS WHAT WE WANT TO GET TO WHEN
WHEN THEY GET THERE THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
AND WE BELIEVE ACMS.
AS ALREADY BEGUN TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THAT -- AND AND WE BELIEVE
THAT.
OUR CHALLENGE WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OUR USERS ARE
ADEQUATELY TRAINED AND KNOW HOW
TO USE THE SYSTEM EFFECTIVELY.
A INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL LEE --
AND THAT -- EVERY TIME THAT WE
COME OUT WITH ADDITIONAL CHANGES
WE NEED TO REPEAT THAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND RETRAIN.
OF COURSE WHEN NECESSARY AND
TRAINING ONCE A AS A COMMON
ABOARD AND THAT MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION PIECE OF THIS IS
CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS TO
LEVERAGE THE OPTIMUM -- CAPACITY
OF THIS NEW SYSTEM.
THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WAS IN SAY THAT BEFORE YOU
START SPEAK BUT I DIDN'T GET THE
CHANCE BUT I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU.
YOUR LAST BUT NOT LEAST YES I
UNDERSTAND IT BEEN HERE BEFORE
OVER THE YEARS AND FOR SOME
REASON WENT UP LAST MOST THE
TIME ARE WE WERE TOLD ME THAT I
SHOULD COUNTY.
SOUNDED LIKE A COMPLAINT AND I
THINK IT'S GOT TO GO TO THE
RIGHT NOTE BUT I HAVE TO SEE
THIS.
WHEN WE DO HAVE PRE HEARING
PREPARATION?
I GET MOVED UP.
YES OKAY SO THAT THERE'S NO I I
NEED TO KNOW THAT THAT THAT THAT
WORKS FINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS.
HER WORDS BERMAN FINANCE NO
COMMENT.
BRENT METZ KALLIO WE'VE REVIEWED
THIS PROPOSAL HAVE NO CONCERNS.
VERY GOOD SEEMS LIKE A VERY
REASONABLE -- PROPOSAL ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU YOU'VE
COMPLETED OUR DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THIS.
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR TODAY
THANK YOU ALL